alors rebonjour à à toutes et à tous et
pour ceux qui ne nous ont pas rejoint
pour la photo donc bonjour on va
commencer notre audition on va avoir un
timing un peu serré ce matin puisque à
10 on voudrait donc bien sûr à 10h15
pouvoir terminer l'audition hein sans
frustrer personne puisqueaprès on a
l'examen du rapport de notre collègue
Anne-Catherine noisier sur le projet de
loi sur les négociations commerciales
l'examen des amendements qui vont suivre
et c'est surtout parce queà partir de 11
30 certaines membres commissaires qui
font également partie de certaines
délégations je crois que les délégations
sont installées aujourd'hui à 11h30 en
tout cas c'est celle de des entreprises
mais je pense que c'est toutes les
délégations
Olivier ah non il y en avait qui était
ce matin très très tôt d'accord al nous
nous c'est c'est midi mais il y a une
réunion 11h30 ah il y a une réunion à
11h30 pour lesr d'accord d'accord bon
voilà donc au moins qu'à 11h30 on est
pratiquement si après on doit encore un
petit peu discuter pour ceux qui reste
mais qu'on ait passé le rapport
d'annecatherine noisier et bien sûr les
procédures de vote qu'elle puisse avoir
été faite
donc mes chers collègues nous recevons
ce matin Madame Laure verdau qui est
directrice de l'Agence française pour le
développement et la promotion de
l'agriculture biologique plus connu sous
le nom d'agence bio ainsi que Monsieur
Philippe camburé qui est le président de
la fédération nationale d'agriculture
biologique pour évoquer avec eux la
situation et les enjeux de l'agriculture
biologique nos deux invités ont un
positionnement différents l'Agence Bio
est un groupement d'intérêt public dont
le ministère de l'agriculture et les
Chambres d'agriculture sont membres
chargés de promouvoir l'agriculture
biologique et d'en expliquer les
principes au consommateur la fédération
nationale d'agriculture biologique
est-elle un syndicat de producteurs avec
de ce fait un regard si vous me le
permettez un peu plus militant en cette
période d'inflation à deux chiffres des
prises alimentaires et dans la
perspective de la prochaine loi
d'orientation agricole il me paraît
important d'entendre les acteurs de
cette filière importante pour notre
agriculture et notre souveraineté
alimentaire 20 % des agriculteurs en
France en moyenne plus jeunes sont
engagés dans l'agriculture biologique
comme nous aimons à le rappeler au sein
de cette commission l'agriculture
française est une agriculture plurielle
et c'est bien ce qui fait sa force
l'agriculture biologique attire encore
aujourd'hui de nombreux candidats à
l'installation désireux de concilier une
nécessaire productivité seul à même de
générer du revenu et d'approvisionner
notre marché et un respect de standards
environnementaux supérieurs à ce déjà
élevé de l'agriculture conventionnelle
cependant depuis de nombreux mois
maintenant on observe un assez net repli
de la consommation de produits issus de
l'agriculture biologique ce repli est
accrédité par le panorama 2022 de
l'Agence Bio qui fait état d'une part du
bio dans le panier des Français de 6 %
en
2022 contre 6,4 % en
2021 soit près de 600 millions d'euros
de chiffre d'affaires en moins pour
l'agriculture biologique le recul est
particulièrement marqué sur le les
segments des viandes traiteur produit de
la mer surgelés et fruits et légumes
alors que les prix du bio certes bien
plus élevés de plus de 100 % pour les
grandes cultures 70 % pour les fruits et
légumes 30 % pour la viande et et 20 à
30 % pour le lait ont en moyenne
augmenté moins vite que le reste des
prises alimentaires en cette période
d'inflation la filière bio étant très
dépendante de la consommation à domicile
cette baisse nous interroge forcément
sur la dynamique de la filière simple
mauvaise passe conjoncturel ou symptômes
d'une politique de montée en gamme
incantatoire peu réfléchie et mal
accompagné
en témoigne la multiplication des
fermetures d'enseignes spécialisées près
de 200 entre 2021 et
2022 et la tendance se poursuit en 2023
à noter que dans ce contexte morose la
vente directe tire nettement son épingle
du jeu ce qui confirme la pétance
grandissante des consommateurs pour les
circuit court cette crise de laaval se
ressent forcément à l'amont avec un
solde des conversion certes toujours
positif mais en forte baisse en 2022 par
rapport à
2021 nous n'assistons pas à un phénomène
massif de déconversion mais d'ors et
déjà à une baisse des conversions
parfois freiné par les coopératives et
les transformateurs songeons que le
groupe Lactalis avait fait état pour
l'année 2021 d'un taux de déclassement
du lait bio de 40 % et que depuis
2021 près d'un million de poules bio ont
été déconverties et la crise s'étendrait
maintenant aux céréales dans ce contexte
dressé à grand trait quel levier
identifiez-vous pour inverser cette
tendance baissière je crois savoir donc
Madame la Directrice que l'Agence Bio
place beaucoup d'espoir dans une relance
par la demande par exemple via la hausse
des achats de produits bio en
restauration collective conformément aux
dispositions de la loi égalime or les
cantines scolaires font-elles aussi face
à une flambé de leur coût ce qui rend
l'équation particulièrement délicate
nous sommes bien placés ici au Sénat la
chambre des territoires pour le savoir à
contrario a-t-on à s creuser la piste
d'une politique de l'offre consistant à
structurer la filière par le
développement notamment des industries
de transformation point faible du Bio
soulne dans le rapport de la Cour des
comptes de 2022 par ailleurs selon
l'Agence Bio 73 % des pertes du bio en
valeur vont vers d'autres offres
labelllisé notamment vers la
certification haute valeur
environnementale qui a un coût pour nos
finances publiques mais semble-t-il pas
d'effet observés sur l'environnement ou
encore des allégations du type zéro
résidu de pesticides cela semble
accréditer
qu'une concurrence des labels se fait
bel et bien au détriment des plus
sérieux d'entre eux comme l'avait avancé
dès 2022 notre collègue Fabien Guay ici
présent et deux anciens collègues de
notre commission François Serra et
Florence blatrix conta dans leur rapport
information du consommateur privilégier
la qualité à la profusion comment
concrètement remédier à cette situation
voilà quelques questions auxquelles je
présume vous allez donc pouvoir nous
répondre je vous laisse la parole sans
plus tarder à l'un comme à l'autre et
ensuite nos collègues sénateurs je ne
doute pas auront de très nombreuses
questions à vous poser est-ce que vous
commencez Madame la directrice de
l'Agence Bio alors on vous laisse la
parole ensuite monsieur le Président
prendra la
suite merci beaucoup bonjour à tous
alors je me permettrait de rebondir sur
ces chiffres pour vous donner un peu de
de couleur sur actuellement la demande
effectivement on est dans une situation
inédite un marché d'habitude se pilote
par l'offre et la demande jusqu'ici on
avait tellement de demande en bio
jusqu'à y a encore 2 ans que on ne
s'occupait que de développer l'offre
dans les champs et nous avons un
objectif national de 18 % de surface en
bio dire décréter 18 % de surface en bio
dans les champs en fait si on se met à
produire du bio dans les champs mais que
personne ne le mange dans les villes
nous avons un problème or c'est ce qui
se passe depuis 2 ans
puisqueeffectivement nous mangions 6
et5i % de bio et nous avons ici la part
de de courses que nous dépensons en bio
à 6 %. cela nous met au niveau des
États-Unis nous la patrie du bien
manger pour d'un coup de baguette
magique supprimer les problèmes du
secteur bio il suffirait de doubler
notre raort en en bio si on mangeait
demain 12 % de bio on aurait un marché à
30 milliards au lieu de 12 milliards
franchement tout irait bien et ça
absorberait la demande de bio dans les
chambres parce que j'y reviendrai nous
avons des agriculteurs qui des
agricultrices qui veulent passer en bio
et nous avons surtout besoin de R
emplacer les nouvelles générations
puisque nous avons 100000 départs la
retraite à préparer et nous allons avoir
une saéé démographique si nous les nous
les remplaçons pas or nous savons que
les fils et les filles d'agriculteur
vont pas suffire pour remplacer les
départs à la retraite il va falloir
recruter des talents à l'extérieur il va
falloir recruter des gens au métier
agricole d'autres secteurs c'est les
fameux nimas les non Isus du milieu
agricole or qu'est-ce qu'on sait des
nimas c'est qu'ils ont très envie d'être
en bio pour la moitié d'entre eux donc
on pourrait difficilement leur refuser
le droit au bio parce que ça ferait une
saie démographique donc je reviens à la
demande nous mangeons 6 % de bio il
faudra en manger 12 %. ça vous là vous
sans doute vous dites c'est fantaisiste
mais figurez-vous que nos voisins
européens que soit les Danois les
Autrichiens les Suédois même les Suisses
sont quelque part entre 10 et 13 % et
même nos voyens j'aime bien l'exemple
allemand les Allemands sont à 9 %. donc
a priori nous France patriie du bien
manger nous pourrions tout à fait
accueillir plus de bu au quotidien dans
nos courses mais pas que dans nos
courses j'aimerais vraiment que à chaque
fois que vous examinez le marché du bio
vous d vous pensez à trois débouché
potentiel il y a certes la consommation
à domicile qui est insuffisante et qui
sur laquelle repose et dépendant le
marché bio puisque c'est 92 % des
débouchés qui s'offrent aux agriculteurs
il n'y a que 8 % du bio qui est mangé à
l'extérieur du foyer c'est-à-dire que ce
soit la cantine et en restauration
commerciale alors ce marché bio donc il
faut absolument qu'il soit relancé dans
la consommation à domicile mais il faut
aussi qu'il soit mis en conformité avec
la loi égalim chaque fois qu'on ne
respecte pas les 20 % de bio fixé par la
loi égalim c'est 15liard qui échappe de
business à nos agriculteurs français et
le troisème segment auquel j'aimerais
vraiment que vous pensiez
systématiquement et je suis d'autant
plus sensible que j'ai pu voir qu'à
votre restaurant il n'y a pas de bio la
carte c'est la restauration commerciale
en France nous avons 170000
restaurants
pardon bah il peut être tout à fait
aussi bon mais avec un peu plus de bio
pour servir les objectifs nationaux
actuellement 170000 restaurants en
France donc je je ne parle pas que des
étoiles au Michelin on parle aussi des
kebabs des pizzeria des glaciers des
bistr n'achèteent que 1 % de leur d
alimentaire en bio là aussi c'est une
perte d'opportunité colossale pour nos
agriculteurs français donc on pourrait
imaginer demain qu'on peut modeler parce
qu' un marché ça ce modèle personne ne
sa'est roulé par terre pour acheter des
voitures électriques on a construit le
marché de la voiture électrique si on
imagine que le bio c'est un peu la
voiture électrique de nos assiettes on
pourrait tout à fait modeler cette
consommation de bio donc
actuellement on a tendance aussi à
mettre tout sur le l'inflation qui a bon
dos mais rappelons que l'inflation est 4
moins élevé en bio et surtout
que on ne pourra pas faire la transition
alimentaire en faisant juste
copiercoller nos listes de courses
habituelles il va falloir notre chariot
a pris 15 % c'est le moment de le
repenser or ce qui se passe c'est que on
a tendance à tout mettre dans le même
sac or si je permettez-moi un peu de
segmentation nous avons 68 millions de
concitoyens 100 millions sont certes en
situation de précarité alimentaire et il
est indispensable que le bio fasse
partie de l'aide alimentaire en revanche
nous avons 58 millions de de
consommateurs /ash citoyen qui sont
encore en situation de faire des
arbitrages nous avons même un tiers
d'entre eux pour qui l'inflation est
quasi indolore que se passe-t-il ils ne
font plus l'arbitrage en faveur du bio
c'est-à-dire que ils vont effectivement
comme vous l'avez très bien dit madame
la Présidente préférer des des labels
enfin je pas alors déjà ne parlons pas
de label parce que c'est pas des
diplômes d'état c'est pas des labels
c'est des allégations marketing ils vont
préférer sans doute acheter un cochon
dit bien élevé sur l'emballage plutôt
que un cochon bio il y a rien de plus
subjectif que bien élevé mes amis
trouvent leurs enfants bien élevé bref
donc on a vraiment besoin de réorienter
les arbitrages de redonner envie de bio
or qu'est-ce qui se passe c'est que on a
des arbitrages les Français ont encore
des marges de manœuvre mais il ils ne le
leur marges de manœuvre ne servent pas
au bio or c'est la seule consommation
individuelle dont il est prouvé par la
recherche par les agences de l'eau par
l'Office français de la biodiversité
qu'il rapporte au collectif chaque fois
que vous vous mangez bio vous baissez la
facture de dépollution de l'eau de tout
le monde chaque fois que moi je mange
bio j'augmente la la biodiversité de 30
% donc il y a vraiment un le bio est un
label d'État c'est le label d'État la
plaque de de la transition
agroécologique et chaque chaque centime
investi sur le bio rapporte au collectif
donc c'est très dommage que la
consommation des Français se se disperse
donc il faut redonner envie de bio et
c'est pour ça que nous nous pensons que
la la première chose qui relancera le
bio c'est le fait que les consommateurs
en veuillent de nouveau par exemple on a
beaucoup entendu parler de la grande
distribution qui retirre le bio des
rayons mais en fait c'est normal ils
sont là pour vendre des choses qui
s'achètent il faut que on va pas leur
demander de faire autre chose donc il
faut que les gens aient de nouveau envie
de bio donc on a 58 millions de Français
qui ont continué d'acheter du café en
capsule à 80 € le kil des salades en
sachet de l'eau en bouteille toutes
sortes de choses où on aurait pu
imaginer que ben ça s'effondrerait avec
l'inflation or ça ne s'est pas effondré
donc il n'y a pas du tout eu la même
baisse qu'il y a eu pour concernant la
la les produits bio donc le la première
chose à faire c'est de remodeler une
demande les Français nous le savons
parce que nous avons eu des fonds
supplémentaires du masa ne savent plus
ce qu'est le bio nous avons fait un
focus group avec des consommateurs ils
nous ont dit ah c'est le truc où il y a
5 % de
pesticides non pas du tout donc en fait
il faut reprendre les bases et il y a un
déficite jusqu'ici le bio était un peu
le grand muet c'est un peu le Bernardo
puisque de toute façon on allait pas
faire de la pub pour des produits dont
on en avait pas assez sauf que
maintenant il y a trois choses qui me
font cruellement défaut au à nos
citoyens pour qu'ils deviennent des
consommateurs éclairés c'est un savoir
ce qu'est le bio un label d'État garanti
par 10 organismes agréés par l'État
indépendant production sans pesticid de
synthèse puis qu'il voit bien
l'actualité sur les pesticides de
synthèse dans les nafriatiques qui uvre
au bien-être animal qui laisse des
mètres carrés qui aux animaux et cetera
la deuxième chose qu'ils doivent
absolument savoir c'est pourquoi c'est
bon pourquoi est-ce que quand lin Rae
décide de faire un métaprogramme bio et
de mettre 300 chercheurs sur le coup on
constate que le bio a des bienfaits pour
le climat pour le carbone pour les sols
pour les les abeilles les cxines bref et
puis pour le bonheur des agriculteurs je
me permets une incis nous avons publié
un baromètre du moral des agriculteurs
bio et et on voit que si on veut des
agriculteurs eururos le bio contribue
nettement à leur bonheur et ils se
sentent engagés dans une agriculture
citoyenne ils attendent donc que comme
ils sont engagés pour le collectif le
collectif s'engage pour
eux donc nous avons actuellement besoin
de passer ces trois messages qui sont un
ce qu' est le bio de pourquoi c'est bon
et tr comment est-ce qu'on en mange quel
que soit son poir d'achat et là on est
sur deux Horizont temps à très court
terme pour redonner les clés pour
redonner la consommation il faut faire
des campagnes pour expliquer de façon
Prati pratique comment est-ce qu'on met
plus de bio dans l'assiette à budget
inchangé parce que oui c'est possible le
bio est accessible pour tout le monde
moyennant une transition alimentaire
c'estàdire que si demain on gaspille
beaucoup moins qu'on cuisine beaucoup
plus qu'on achète de saisons qu'on
achète en direct qu'on a on a on varie
nos protéines végétales et animales
mécaniquement la part du bio pourra
augmenter une étude de l'Inra a
d'ailleurs prouvé que entre à pouvoir
d'achat égal l'éducation est clé c'estàd
qu'entre une famille ils ont pris un
carrotage même même CSP entre des
familles qui mangent beaucoup de bio et
des familles qui ne mange pas de bio il
y a 12 points d'écart dans leur budget
alimentaire respectif c'est pas donc
deux fois plus cher de manger
bio c'est 12 points d'écart pourquoi
parce qu'il n'achète pas la même chose
il ne l'achète pas au même endroit il
n'achète pas la même quantité donc on a
tout à fait les moyens de modeler cette
cette cette consommation nous avons deux
objectifs
nationaux c'est pour ça que pour moi il
n'y a pas de question enfin la montée en
gamme qui se fait c'est pas forcément le
le bon le bon vocable pour parler du bio
on a objectif national de développer le
bio parce que les Français aiment bien
avoir un agriculteur bio comme voisin
ils aiment bien aller faire leur jogging
à côté d'un champ bio pourtant quand ils
franchissent la porte du supermarché
mais ils vont pas forcément mettre du
bio dans leur dans leur dans leur panier
on a un peu le même ce même gap cette
même dissonnance cognitive quand les
gens vous disent je ne regarde caré que
vous regardez les chiffres d'audience il
y a TF1 qui est en en en tête c'est un
peu il faudrait pouvoir réduire ce
décalage entre le déclaratif et les
actions pour ça il faut éduquer et donc
éduquer par des campagnes d'information
massives prtic pratique à des heures de
grande écoute idéalement tous les soirs
à 20 an à 20h répéter les produits bio
des sensations pures les produits bio
nos amis pour la vie et puis il faudrait
sur le long terme commencer à éduquer
maintenant les enfants qui sont en
petite en grande section de maternelle
vont sortir et vont être vont partir de
chez leurs parents en 2035 cette
génération 2035 pour qu'elle soit pas à
la mercie de de marque de d'agro
alimentaire ou de chaîne de fast food il
faut l'éduquer maintenant pour qu'elle
soit parce que on sait avec un assez bon
degré de certitude que un citoyen
informé devient un consommateur averti
une fois qu'il est en train de faire ses
courses donc je conclurai sur le fait
que nous avons donc deux objectifs
nationaux 18 % de bio dans les champs
mais pas forcément 18 % de bio dans
l'assiette on a 20 % de bio mais que
dans l'assiette de la restauration
collective il faut qu'on puisse avoir
comme indicateur le vrai indicateur sur
lequel nous devrions avoir les yeux
rivés c'est notre tau de consommation de
bio en gros il fautrait qu'on devienne
danois qu'on mange 12 % de bio donc
c'est les 20 % qui sont proclamés par
égalim dans les cantines nous ne sommes
qu'à 7 % c'est une perte de chance pour
nos agriculteurs et pour cela je
conclurai juste sur les je sais que vous
êtes tous plus ou moins très au courant
de Pat qui sont dans vos territoirees
les Pat ont bénéficié de 80 millions de
d'euros de financement public sans
jamais qu'il soit il y a des Pat qui
sont rédigés sans jamais qu'il a le
Mobio donc c'est assez surprenant et
donc comme certains Pat permettent
également de faire l'éducation
alimentaire perett également de parler
de précarité alimentaire nous pensons
que le le l'avenir de du bio pourrait
passer par une mention plus systématique
notamment du bio comme objectif et de
surtout que les Pat servent ces deux
objectifs nationaux de bio
voilà merci Madame la Directrice
monsieur le
Président merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames Messieurs pour votre votre
votre écoute ce
matin je voudrais juste compléter le le
la présentation que vous vous aviez
faite déjà déjà très précise par par
quelques faits justement de la part des
des agricultrices et des agriculteurs
qui sont en bio aujourd'hui et qui sont
encore nombreux à se demander s'ils ont
s'ils ont fait le bon choix s'ils ont
fait le bon choix il y a 2 ans 5 ans ou
même il y a 40 ans pour les plus anciens
d'entre eux qui vont maintenant partir
en retraite bientôt et qui se demandent
si leur ferme qui est passé en bio il y
a 40 ans ou qui même peut-être n'a
jamais été autre chose que du bio va
pouvoir rester en bio ce constat
aujourd'hui il est dans toutes les
fermes dans toutes les régions dans tous
les secteurs de production ou
quasiment et ce constat il est
finalement le le
résultat du décrochage de la
consommation je je je reviendrai pas
dessus ça a déjà été cité mais le
désarroi des agricultrices des
agriculteurs bio aujourd'hui il est
aussi finalement le résultat de choix
politiques qui ont été fait très
ambitieux et qu'on a toujours salué et
qu'on saluera toujours d'aller vers ces
18 % euh à la fin de la PAC mais 21 % si
la planification écologique va au bout
de ses résultats on a toujours salué ces
ambitions là sauf que ces ambitions là
n'ont pas toujours été considérées comme
suffisamment fragilees par moment pour
mériter le soutien qui était qui était
en face à tel point qu'en
force force éta de constaté qu'on avait
des des croissances à plusieurs chiffres
qui qui faisaient sûrement envie à plein
d'autres secteurs et et et le choix a
été fait de de laisser l'oiseau
s'envoler sans finalement s'assurer de
la pérenité de la solidité sauf que
quand on quand on a des croissances
forte mais qu'on est déjà à des niveaux
de pénétration de 10 15 20 % il y a pas
de problème on peut considérer qu'on a
une inertie et qu'on va pouvoir
supporter des aléas de la consommation
et des aléas de lande ça n'était
certainement pas le cas en 2017 et donc
les paiements pour services
environnementaux de l'époque qui
s'appelait aide au maintien à l'époque
mais qui n'était finalement rien d'autre
que ça c'est p pour services
environnementaux sont passés à la trappe
et on a considéré que c'était le marché
donc l'aspiration du marché de la
consommation qui allait faire le travail
sauf que on voit très bien que la
consommation c'est pas quelque chose
qu'on pilote du bout des doigts c'est
pas quelque chose qu'on qu'on anticipe
longtemps à l'avance on voit bien et on
retrouve depuis plusieurs mois la
conscience de nos fragilités et c'est ce
choix aujourd'hui donc de laisser
finalement le marché gérer
le développement du projet bio français
c'est ce constat là qui fait que on a du
désarroi dans les fermes et c'est pour
ça que finalement on fait le constat que
comme n'importe quelle autre filière
agricole ou filière
économique on a besoin justement d'une
structuration vous l'avez dit vous
l'avez dit madame la Présidente une
structuration digne de ce nom qu'on ne
laisse pas simplement ces ces paysans
bio s'amuser dans leur coin s'organiser
comme ils veulent pourvu que il la
ramènent pas pas trop excusez-moi je
vais prendre la parole un peu plus
militante que vous avez cité tout à
l'heure mais je vais pas dépasser ne ne
laissons pas simplement une affaire se
dérouler comme ça entre entre averti et
et dans l'entre soi d'une d'une nouvelle
niche agricole nous sommes des
entreprises à part entières nous sommes
des des exploitations agricoles à part
entière nous sommes reconnus comme tel
et de ce fait nous avons forcément
besoin par moment comme n'importe qui en
a besoin de structures fortes et de
soutien de ces structures fortes
et pour prendre exemple dans des
filières agricoles qui dans toute leur
histoire ont connu effectivement ces
alias ces alias de consommation que ce
soit que ce soit sur du vin du porc du
lait enfin je je ferai pas la liste tout
ratour toutes les filières à peu près à
un moment de leur histoire connaissent
ce genre de décrochage de la
consommation par rapport à l'offre offre
demande évidemment on a besoin d'avoir
un regard prospectif tant qu'on a des
indicateurs disponibles pour qu'on
puisse anticiper les choses et
malheureusement quand le décrochage
devient trop important on a besoin de
réguler aujourd'hui vous l'avez dit on a
un décrochage fort de la consommation
qui fait qu'on a du déclassement des
produits bio répondant à un cahier des
charges strict se retrouve aujourd'hui
mélangé au milieu de tous les autres
produits par déclassements 30 40 % par
moment dans certaines filières donc ce
constat
jamais jamais on le ferait dans une
autre dans une autre filière jamais dans
une autre filière on ne laisserait les
les productrices et les
producteurs prendre sur leur propre
trésorerie leur propre solidité
financière 30 à 40 % de perte de revenu
jamais donc aujourd'hui notre vision
parfois militante mais en tout cas
économique des choses c'est que les
outils de régulation de marché qui sont
aujourd'hui disponibles soit pour la
réduction volontaire de produ
soit pour de l'aide au stockage de
l'aide à la transformation enfin en
existe des tonnes à l'échelle française
mais aussi évidemment sur sur des
dinamique européenne ces outilsl
aujourd'hui montrent leur limite par
rapport à la filière bio par des niveaux
de seuil par des niveaux de de
complexité technique qui font on est
bien à la peine aujourd'hui de réunir
les outils nécessaires pour que on
puisse conforter la
production on a à travailler avec vous
parlementairire avec le ministère sur la
création ou la modification des des
outils existants de façon à ce que on se
prémunisse contre ce genre de d'Ala à
l'avenir avec un peu plus de moyens
évidemment sur la demande parce qu'on
est encore pas au rendez-vous on le sait
même si des des annonces plutôt
encourageantes viennent d'être
faites on aura
besoin de de soutenir l'offre dans la
mesure où l'inertie de la demande elle
sera forcément rendez-vous c'est pas
parce qu'aujourd'hui on va
dépenser des millions et des millions
d'euros de de de spot de pub dans la
pendant la mi-temps de des match de de
n'importe quelle compétition qu'on aura
une relance immédiate on a de l'inertie
de façon de façon structurelle et on
aura besoin au moins pendant pendant
l'année à venir sans doute pendant
plusieurs années qui viennent d'avoir
des outils qui répondront à ces
objectifs là pour ne pas
décourager mes collègues qui sont qui
qui ont fait ce pas en avant pour ne pas
donner ce signal contreproductif dans
une année où on a travaillé sur un
projet de loi d'orientation agricole sur
le renouvellement des générations quelle
réponse la France va donner à tous ces
candidats à l'installation en
agriculture si on les décourage d'emblé
en leur disant que il y a pas de place
pour la bio demain donc ces enjeuxl
doivent être coordonnés de manière
transversale et la la solution est
certainement plrien
monsieur le ministre de l'Agriculture
tient à cet objectif de 18 % à la fin de
la programmation de la PAC
c'est c'est une une posture qui mérite
évidemment d'être salué aujourd'hui on
ne manque pas de l'interroger sur les
moyens mis en œuvre pour respectecter ça
parce que 2023 malheureusement risque
d'être l'année du recul de l'agriculture
bio en France préparons-nous à ce
constat préparons-nous d'ors et déjà à à
à avoir une donnée 2024 du retour à à
des à des horizons plus plus rassurants
et puis finalement plus rassurant pour
l'ensemble des transitions dans
lesquelles on est on est engagé
aujourd'hui que ce soit la biodiversité
le carbone j'en passe et des meilleurs
l'enjeu des transitions aujourd'hui ne
pourra pas faire l'économie de
l'agriculture biologique merci de votre
attention merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Directrice vous vouliez
rajouter deux mots et ensuite on va
passer aux questions parce que le temps
défile juste pour la complète
information de de cette salle nous
sommes actuellement champions d'Europe
de bio en surface nous avons 2,8
millions d'ctar nous pouvons avoir un
cocorico bio et l'Espagne est d'ailleurs
très embêté d'avoir perdu son leadership
et pour rebondir effectivement nous
risquons de voir ces 10 % de surface
àoué au bio reculé cette année pour
l'instant ça ne se voit pas dans les
chiffres ça sera sans doute en fin
d'année et notre nos 60000 fermes bio
sont notre patrimoine national donc si
demain elle devait régresser ce serait
un appauvrissement de de notre de notre
patrimoine agric ça c'est une première
chose et ma deuxième chose c'est que
nous avons pas abordé la question de la
souveraineté mais le bio est un outil de
souveraineté alimentaire actuellement
nous
produisons 70 % du bio que nous
consommons en France c'està-dire 70 % du
bio consommé en France et made in France
et si on retire de ce chiffre les
produits tropicaux qui ne poussent pas
sous nos latitudes les bananes les
amandes les chocolats on monte à 82 % de
bio consommé en France Médine France le
bio est donc un excellent élève de la
souveraineté alimentaire d'autant plus
qu'il permet de ne pas creuser le
déficit en anglais synthétique en
angrais azoté puisqu'il n'en utilise pas
et nous avons quand même un déficit
commercial en angrais d'un milliard 4
merci merci à à tous les deux donc je
vais céder la parole à l'ensemble de nos
collègues simplement pour la bonne
organisation des débats et par rapport
au timing qui nous est imposé donc on a
actuellement 18 inscrits je suis pas sûr
qu'on arrive tous à passer à poser la
question on va essayer je demande aussi
à la fois Madame la directrice et à
monsieur le Président d'être le plus
synthétique dans leur réponse mais comme
je demande aussi à nos collègues d'être
également très synthétiqu dans leurs
questions pour essayer que l'ensemble
des collègues inscrits puisse poser la
question d'abord on va faire un juste un
tir groupé des trois rapporteurs de la
mission agriculture donc Laurent Duplomb
Franck menanville et Jean-Claude tisso
et ensuite on fera les
questions-réponses dynamiques et assez
courtes dans les deux sens donc Laurent
Duplomb Franck Ménonville Jean-Claude
tissau qui sont nos rapporteurs dans le
cadre du PLF sur la mission
agriculture merci Madame madame la
Présidente voilà maintenant quelques
décennies que l'agriculture biologique
prospère en partie sur une fausse
promesse car beaucoup trop politisé
voire même beaucoup trop dans
l'idéologie cette illusion qui s'est
maintenant répandue à d'autres secteurs
économiques c'est celle d'une production
immaculée d'un travail de l'homme ne
laissant aucune trace sur son
environnement résultat les Français ne
savent pas pour une bonne partie d'entre
eux que l'agriculture biologique
autorise elle aussi de pesticides les
réactions indignées au complément
d'enquête d'il y a quelques semaines sur
le sujet l'ont montré et on peut dire
que vous ne vous êtes pas démené pour
dissiper ce malentendu d'une production
agricole soi-disant sans pesticides et
sans engrais vous-même connaissez les
cahiers des charges et savez très bien
que dans la réalité tout est à faire
malheureusement ou heureusement de
bénéfice risque vous êtes même placé
pour vous êtes même bien placé pour
savoir que l'agriculture fait parfois
face à ce que l'on appelle des impasses
techniques j'en veux pour preuve l'usage
du cuivre fongicide pour contrer le
mildou et la tablelure utilisé par tout
le monde mais d'autant plus en
agriculture biologique que d'autres
substances lui sont interdites avec des
effets délétaires sur la vie des sols
une expertise scientifique collective
menée par linra E en 2018 a donneré
quelques pistes pour s'en passer mais
laisse autant de questions que de
réponses comme souvent dans ces sujets
j'aurais donc deux questions
premièrement pouvez-vous nous dire où en
êtes-vous 5 ans après sur ce rapport
dans la recherche d'alternative ou la
réduction des usages de cuivre
deuxièmement vous qui vous montrez si
prend à dénoncer le moindre écart dans
les alégations des labels concurrents
qu'attendez-vous pour faire le ménage
dans votre propre maison en rappelant à
l'ordre ceux qui en véhiculant une
fausse image de l'agriculture biologique
finissent par jeter le dis crédit sur la
l'agriculture française dans son
intégralité pour une entrée en matière
Franck Menonville et ensuite Jean-Claude
tisau oui merci madame la présidente
Madame la Directrice monsieur le le
président une question très simple
est-ce que l'agriculture biologique
aujourd'hui ne ne finalement ne fait pas
les frais
de de de l'organisation politique qui a
été la la sienne et notamment partant de
d'objc
fixé politiquement quant à des objectifs
de production à des objectifs de de
consommation nétant pas suffisamment
connecté et structuré au marché depuis
un certain nombre de de de lois ça a été
le cas sous le le ministre Lefol ça a
été le cas par la suite on finalement on
oriente des objectifs de production des
objectifs de de surface on
accompagne des des des conversions et on
se donne parallèlement pas les moyens
d'être d'être
suffisamment connecté au marché connecté
aussi à la demande du du consommateur
avec sans doute aussi des des des des
outils de
transformation trop peu présents et trop
peu
structuré sur les territoires voilà un
peu la la donc finalement ma question
c'est comment faire en sorte d'Ali
objectif mais également objectif
politique si ça c'est le choix des
politiques mais aussi réalité réalité
économique réalité des des marchés
réalité de des consommateurs merci franc
Jean-Claude tissau merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Président Madame
la Directrice moi je tire pas à balle
réelle mais avec notre collègue DUP
plomb on a des visions différentes sur
ce thème là je vous remercie déjà de vos
exposés liminire qui illustre les
nombreux intérêts de l'agriculture R et
de son développement et pour ma part
j'aurais quelques questions
complémentaires pourir venir sur les
différentes aides à l'agriculture bio
que vous avez évoqué je souhaitais
savoir quel est votre regard sur les
pertinences de ces aides que ce soit en
volume ou sur le ciblage et est-ce que
les critères retenus sont pertinents
l'aide de 60 millions d'euros annoncé en
mai dernier par le ministre de
l'Agriculture est une première étape
mais elle me paraît quand même bien
maigre pour atteindre l'objectif des 18
% vous l'avez dit Madame la Directrice
la SAU en bio d'ici 2027 enfin je
souhaitais aborder la concurrence
intraeuropéenne et extraeuropéenne sur
les produits issus de l'agriculture bio
on évoque très souvent la concurrence
sur l'agriculture dite conventionnelle
mais que pouvez-vous nous dire sur la
concurrence que subit l'agriculture
biologique française et je pense
notamment au produits espagnol vous
l'avez dit aussi vous en avez parlé
aussi madame la la directrice il me
semble que l'une des réponses pour le
bio français devrait être de renforcer
le lien entre l'agribio et le localisme
pour répondre à ses concurrences autant
sur le prix que sur l'impact
environnemental et enfin ma dernière
question portera sur le lien
indispensable avec les collectivités
territoriales et les établissements
scolaires on le sait et on retravaille
dessus le pourcentage de produits issus
deagri bio dans les cantines reste bien
en dessous des objectifs avec seulement
6 % de produits bio dans les cantines en
2022 comment expliquez-vous ce
développement difficile et est-ce
seulement lié à la structuration des
filières merci je vous laisse la parole
pour répondre à ces trois
interventions merci beaucoup alors je
suis un peu euh je suis un peu triste
parce que ça veut dire vous n'êtes pas
allé sur le site de l'Agence Bio puisque
nous avons fait une infographie
justement nous voulons vraiment que le
citoyen en fait nous on n pas d'action
en bio que le bio se vende ou pas on on
est pas payé plus à la fin donc on veut
juste que s'il choisit ou pas le bio le
citoyen le fasse de manière éclairée
donc nous on a aucune aucun intérêt à
propager des faux des faux bruits
surtout on est sous la tutelle du
ministère de l'Agriculture vous doutez
bien qu'on va pas nous laisser faire
dans cette infographie que nous avons
largement diffusée nous montrons qu'il y
a actuellement 455 substances chimiques
autorisées en Europe pour faire de
l'agriculture et que le bu on utilise 47
dont le cuivre que nous saons
expressément donc pourquoi parce que
nous expliquons la différence entre la
chimie naturelle et la chimie
synthétique pour revenir sur le cuivre
je regrette qu'à chaque fois le débat
soit capturé sur le cuivre le cuivre
c'est un petit point du pixel alors
j'aimerais vraiment qu'on ait la Big
Picture la grande photo du bio ce matin
le bio n'utilise pas plus de cuivre
puisque c'est 4 kg par an par hectare et
surtout on na jamais fermé un captage
d'eau nous avons 36000 captages d'eau en
France les agences de l'eau n' a n ont
jamais fermé à cause d'une poll au
cuivre jamais et alors qu'il y en a 100
qui sont fermés pour pollution agricole
deuxième point le cuivre il est vendu en
complément alimentaire dans les
pharmacies donc le grand méchant cuivre
bon je je pense que c'est dommage que de
se focaliser sur ce point de détail où
l'amélioration continue qui est dans
l'ADN des bio est en œuvre et que
effectivement tout est fait pour se
passer de ce de cuivre et j'encourage à
ce qu'on finance largement plus la
recherche pour dépasser cet impasse
technique sur le cuivre par ailleurs
vous avez parlé de fauses promesses du
bio alors moi je je suis peut-être pas
de la génération où on a cru que le bio
enfin faisait revenir l'être aimé et se
et résolvait tous les problèmes de
l'existence en revanche nous avons
besoin maintenant que c'est un produit
de masse pas juste un produit d'initier
de militant que chacun sache ce qu'il en
est c'est pour ça que nous appelons à
avoir un budget de communication et
d'information du citoyen au quotidien
mais aussi nous appelons à pouvoir faire
rentrer le bio dans l'éducation
alimentaire de façon à avoir des
citoyens éclairés là-dessus concernant
les objectifs fixés par un marché pour
un marché c'est effectivement un marché
dans la mesure où on décide de on veut
développer une offre en face il faut
développer une demande jusqu'ici la
question ne s'était pas posée mais vous
parlez des infrastructures qui
permettent de de relier les différents
maillons de la chaîne consommateur et
producteur je reprendrai l'image de la
voiture électrique quand on a décrété
qu'on allait passer à la voiture
électrique on s'est donné 10 ans et on n
pas juste dit on veut des voitures
électriques on a dit on va créer des
réseaux on va éduquer et on va verser
7000 € par foyer pour qu'ils achètent
des voitures électriques donc c'est
effectivement le marché se doit se de se
penser à l'échelle de tous les maillons
de la chaîne de valeur et c'est pour ça
que je me permettrai du coup d'enchaîner
sur votre
question sur le le le bio
structuré la structuration des filières
nous avons depuis 15 ans depuis le
Grenelle de l'environnement à l'Agence
Bio la la gestion que nous qui nous a
été confiée du fond avenir bio
d'ailleurs vous êtes cordialement invité
aux 15 ans de ce fond avenir bio le 7
décembre prochain à Paris et nous allons
célébrer justement les entrepreneurs du
bio qui ont construit les filières bio
parce que quand dans les années 80 10
2000 tout le monde a voulu manger des
yaourts de lait de chèvre bio mais on
avait pas de chèvre on avait pas de
laitterie on avait pas de yaourterie
donc il a bien fallu créer ces outils là
et le fond à venir bio qui a a financé
300 entrepreneurs du bio a contribué à
monter ces infrastructures là il est
d'ailleurs sur le modèle de France
relance c'est-à-dire qu'on demande
d'abord à des entrepreneurs de venir en
disant j'ai un projet j'ai des débouchés
que j'ai sécurisé et j'embarque dans ma
croissance x agriculteur bio donc c'est
pour ça que nous nous réjouissons que ce
fond àen bio a été renforcé à hauteur de
18 millions d'euros pour la l'année qui
vient et c'est justement un outil de
souveraineté alimentaire parce qu'on
était arrivé à des situations aberrantes
où tout le monde s'est mis à manger du
musel bio on produit de la voine en
France laavine partait en camion en
Allemagne était floconné en Allemagne et
revenait ensuite donc pour ce qui est de
bio et local qui n'ont pas être opposé
les Français nous l'ont montré la
présidente l'a rappelé le le segment en
croissance en 2022 de 4 % alors qu'on a
tous parlé du bio qui chutait 4 % de
croissance dans les ventes en direct des
fermes bio actuellement sur les 60000
fermes bio il y en a 26000 qui vendent
en direct 26000 c'est plus que toute la
grande distribution la grande
distribution c'est 18000 points de vente
sur le territoire donc c'est bien la
preuve qu'entre bio et local est pas
cher parce que notre ex-président par
exemple phppe vous connaissez il vend
ses patates à 1,30 le kilo à la ferme
entre bio local et pas cher les Français
ont plébicité le le bio en direct donc
on se réjouit que les ce soit dans l'ADN
des fermes bio qu'elles vendent en
direct mais là si elle se mettent à
mettre la clé sous la porte on perd une
opportunité de de RET territorialiser
nos fères
alimentairesur président
oui alors pour répondre dans l'ordre
merci merci de toutes vos questions bien
entendu qui montrre que vous êtes vous
êtes au fait de l'actualité avec des
sources
d'information précise
ou ou ou parfois peut-être déjà
elle-même un peu
engagée c'est parfait l'équilibre et et
sur la question du cuivre la question
question des intran controversés en bio
personne n'a prétendu en bio lav plus
blanc que blanc jamais de la vie jamais
de la vie la démarche de progrès dans
notre ADN on fait au fur et à mesure des
alertes ou des soupçons qui peuvent
arriver donc c'est le cas du cuivre
c'est le cas d'autres d'autres produits
de biocontrôle d'origine naturelle qui
présentent semble-t-il parfois des
risques à chaque fois on anticipe au
maximum et au sein de notre fédération
la question du cuivre on n pas attendu
un un prochain cache investigation pour
s'en occuper bien entendu on a un petit
peu de financement de l'ordre de
quelques centaines de milliers d'euros
sur des programmes pluriannuels pour
accompagner les agriculteurs dans les
recherches d'alternatives comme à tout
problème on ne doit pas s'interdire
évidemment de rechercher toutes les
alternatives possibles et sur la
question du cuivre c'est bien le cas
évidemment les choses avancent elles
avanceraient plus vite si au niveau de
la recherche et de l'Institut Technique
de l'agriculture biologique notamment
les moyens allouer étaient en
conséquence des enjeux et en conséquence
des préoccupations des citoyennes et des
citoyens donc il y a pas de question sur
les sur les intran controversés en bio
la démarche de progrès c'est toujours
d'être le plus possible en adéquation
avec les enjeux des transitions que ce
soit l'eau la biodiversité mais aussi la
santé
humaine aujourd'hui on a plus à souffrir
ce genre ce genre de remarque là je
pense qu'on l'a montré à à bien à bien
des reprises quant au fubio évidemment
comme tout secteur économique en forte
croissance bah on a tendance à attirer
évidemment des gens qui n'ont pas
forcément une la la la vue la plus la
plus progressiste et la plus la plus
humaniste qui soit quant au quant on au
bienfait pour la société évidemment de
l'opportunisme on en a j'ai des
collègues qui sont opportunistes nous
sommes agriculteurs tous les deux vous
savez bien que notre préoccupation c'est
d'abord de vivre de notre métier la
conception de des possibilités pour
vivre de notre métier elle peut varier
je suis pas là dans un procès
d'intention évidemment simplement
j'espère que on va tous dans le même
sens pour que cette cette critique sur
le faubio cesse le plus souvent possible
et le plus rapidement possible quant à
votre votre question monsieur sur le sur
l'organisation politique finalement pour
atteindre ces objectifs force de
constater que le qu'on aurait
certainement pu être plus plus
précautionneux sur sur l'accompagnement
et et aujourd'hui sans doute on aurait
peut-être per on serait peut-être à
quelques points quelques points de
retard par rapport à ce qu'on a pu
atteindre mais mais ce serait peut-être
des points plus solides on aura
peut-être justement cette inertie qui
nous permettrait de passer la la la la
la période si on avait eu ces outils de
de régulation un peu plus anticipés je
vais juste revenir sur l'actualité
aujourd'hui de de l'agriculture
biologique au sein du ministère vous
êtes vous êtes en mesure de le savoir
aussi on prépare la prochaine la
prochaine version du programme ambition
bio qui sera qui sera présenté en début
d'année prochaine qui est en cours de
travail au sein du du ministère de
l'Agriculture personne dans toutes les
familles professionnelles qui sont dans
la rédaction dans les groupes de travail
de ce programme ambition bio personne ne
remet en question les 18 % tout syndicat
confondu
interprofession personne ne remet cet
objectif là en question donc on y
travaille justement pour que cette
nouvelle version soit d'autant plus
adaptée aux nouveaux enjeux et nouveaux
aux nouveaux risques en alliant
évidemment réalité réalité économique
pour terminer sur sur la pertinence des
des aides monsieur
tisso aujourd'hui l'agriculture
biologique comme toutes les agricultures
est soumis à la politique agricole
commune qui a été choisi il y a
maintenant 1 an et qui est en route pour
5 ans cette politique agricole commune
vous vous le savez a choisi de ratissé
très large pour l'évolution des
pratiques des agriculteurs en leur
offrant un accès à des écorégime qui
montre que aujourd'hui le système est
dépassé par son succès les l'enveloppe
des écorégimes est déjà sioné sursphoné
et le ministère a été obligé de prévoir
20 30 % de réduction déjà sur cette
récompense aux modifications de pratique
la bio l'agriculture biologique en fait
les frais bien évidemment et donc ça va
avoir des conséquences sur les 5 6 ans à
venir et peut-être aussi sur sur cet
objectif de 18 %. sur les fonds
d'urgence qui ont été débloqués le cadre
de l'aide Ukraine entre guillemets
Ukraine des fonds européens avec la
malheureusement la rigidité que ça peut
avoir avec la complexité que ça peut
avoir aujourd'hui on est évidemment loin
loin du compte 60 millions de prévus 100
millions déjà de dossierers arrivés sur
sur les sur les les bureaux des des des
drafs comment on va faire comment on va
faire pour combler ce manque euh le fond
le fond Ukraine ne sera certainement pas
la nouvelle solution mais en tout cas on
va avoir absolument besoin de répondre à
ces agricultrices etes agriculteurs qui
se sont engagés je vais pas revenir sur
ce que je présentais tout à l'heure mais
l'enjeu de de déconversion se montre de
de plus en plus fort vous l'avez dit
cette année en particulier sur les
grandes cultures puisque c'est la
dernière filière à arriver sur le sur ce
niveau de sur ce niveau de tension et
les grandes cultures représentant les
plus grandes surfaces en France risqu
d'avoir le plus grand impact sur les
surfaces bio et sur les surfaces de
protection des captages évidemment les
agences bio sont souvent là pour nous le
rappeler comme l'avait rappelé la Cour
des comptes dans son dans son rapport
pour terminer sur bioé loocalisme
évidemment bioé loocalisme se sont
affrontés pendant les épisodes de
confinement déconfinement successifs les
Françaises et les Français ont
été perturbé par ce cette nouvelle ce
nouvel ordre économique qui s'installait
pour les courses du quotidien ces
perturbation malheureusement les ont
amené à à parfois déprioriser
reprioriser selon des critères qui qui
qui n'était sûrement pas solide et de ce
fait aujourd'hui on a tout à gagner à se
rencontrer à nouveau entre bio et
localisme c'est évidemment la solution
idéale sachant qu'aujourd'hui la plupart
des produits bio sont sont quand même
consommés consommés localement mais
évidemment que cette politique de
d'accompagnement de la de l'offre doit
se faire aussi dans cet objectif là pour
que finalement on arrive à répondre à
toutes les demandes et et ce sera ce
sera le finalement l'intérêt du C de la
citoyenne et du citoyen qui seront qui
s'en sortiront
grandi merci monsieur le Président donc
on va faire question réponse je vous
demande vraiment d'être très court et
s'il y a des questions qui ont déjà été
posées bien sûr bah de d'y renoncer
Alain
Cadec merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Président Madame la
Directrice vous l'avez évoqué tout à
l'heure face à l'inflation qui touche le
pouvoir d'achat des Français ces
derniers sont tiraillés entre leur envie
de consommer mieux pour manger mieux le
critère du prix qui reste le premier
critère dans leur parcours d'achat d
laissant de plus en plus l'alimentation
bio les ventes de produits bio sont en
recul notamment en grande distribution
et en magasins spécialisés les chiffres
annoncés en juin 2023 par l'Agence Bio
pour l'année 2022 confirme les grandes
tendances amorcées en
2021 les achats de produits alimentaires
bio sont en base de 4,6
% et la part du Bio dans le panier des
Français s'établi à 6 % contre 6,4 % en
2021 alors est-ce que les produits aux
mentions alternatives comme HVE
Agriconfiance ou zéro résidus de
pesticides sont vos concurrents directs
plus que l'inflation ou bien la trait
récent pour les produits
locaux si oui avez-vous prévu une
nouvelle stratégie pour récupérer ces
consommateurs qui vont peut-être
aujourd'hui de plus en plus vers des
produits plus accessibles en terme de
prix je vous remercie comme je l'avais
dit dans l'exposé nous avons constaté
qu'il n'y avait pas certains produits
dont on pourrait imaginer qu'ils
auraient été les premières victimes de
l'effondrement du pouvoir d'achat des
Français il en fait il n'y a pas eu
d'effondrements pour des produits comme
par exemple les capsules de café l'eau
en bouteille et cetera vous soullignez
effectivement que les Français sont
tiraillés entre fin du mois et fin du
monde et c'est pourquoi une des
solutions c'est le
le
disons que résumant on n' pas beaucoup
de temps là-dessus le sur ce qui est de
de la communication on a mené plusieurs
études de Kantar avec Quantar avec
Nilsen la Seu consentement à payer des
français actuellement le seul c'est de
soutenir du local ou du français
c'estàdire que la seule chose qui permet
de de faire consentir à surpayer un
produit c'est le bleu blanc rouge c'est
pourquoi nous avons mené une première
campagne avec l'ensemble des
interprofessions leniel Interbev
Interfel on a joué à 10 avec 10 filières
pour faire une première campagne l'an
dernier qui s'appelait pour nous pour la
planète buflex je sais pas si vous
l'avez elle est en tête mais elle est en
ce moment sur les ondes de Radio France
la campagne a marché plus 5 % de
business à la clé pour le bio
c'est-à-dire qu'à chaque fois que la
campagne a été déployée les ventes de
bio ont augmenté de 5 %. c'est pourquoi
nous êes nous sommes actuellement dans
la vague 2 de cette campagne les
interprofessions ramp pil avec nous mais
également les régions sansaisistes les
métropoles puisque l'occcitanie la
Bretagne et
également le Pays de la Loire repris le
ce slogan VI refflex nous l'avons
inffléchi pour cette deuxième vague en
disant pour nous pour la planète pour
nos producteurs locaux parce qu'en fait
l'angle mort et C cette opposition qu'on
a entendu beaucoup dans les médias sur
je mange pas bio je mange local n'a pas
de sens il est temps vraiment de la
débunquer et de montrer qu'en France
plus que dans n'importe quel autre pays
européen on peut faire les deux on peut
produire bio et manger bio made in
France exactement notre filière bio
française ça devrait être notre fierté
nos voisins espagnols et italiens qui
sont des gros producteurs de bio la
mangent pas et l'exportte nos voisins
allemands ne produisent pas de bio mais
l'impimportent nous on peut faire les
deux et donc c'est pourquoi nous
demandons à à à être renforcé nous avons
déjà été renforcés nous demandons à être
renforcé chaque denier public qu'on nous
confit nous le faisons fructuer
fructifier pour qu'il contribue à
augmenter le le marché bio pour tout le
monde donc pour nous pour la planète
burflex et producteurs locaux rapidement
monsie alors très rapidement
la question de l'accessibilité au
produits bio se pose évidemment
elle s'est posé aussi avant même cette
crise là il a été question justement
dans des engagements de de candidats à
la présidentielle de rendre les produits
bio accessibles à tous notamment via des
initiatives comme le le panier
alimentation le panier alimentation
durable ou d'autres initiatives qui
permettaient
justement de de rompre ces ces clivages
qui peuvent rester aujourd'hui dans dans
dans le dans l'esprit commun d'un
produit bio réservé réservé à une élite
donc les initiatives évidemment on ne
souhaiterait que les encourager quitte à
ce que on est avant tout la recherche
d'effet de levier par des opérations
peut-être ponctuelles ou autres mais en
tout cas par des opérations qui viseront
à améliorer ça je prends j'en veux pour
Preve la stratégie nationale
alimentation nutrition climat qui est là
et qui va reprendre en partie au moins
cet objectif de de d'amélioration de
l'accessibilité en ce qui concerne les
mentions les mentions alternatives le le
le constat il est fait au regard de ce
qui se passe dans dans les grandes
surfaces puisque dans les grandes
surfaces il se passe encore quand même
75 à 80 % des achats alimentaires
évidemment que la grande distribution la
grande distribution a eu à répondre à
cette question de l'aliment durable de
l'aliment bon pour la planète de
l'aliment bon pour la santé comment
est-ce qu'elle y a répondu elle a
cherché dans tous ses approvisionnements
la façon de valoriser des démarches
tantôt tantôt agronomiqu tantôt
plus citoyenne mais en tout cas elle
s'est engouffrée dans cette dans cette
démarche de distinction de
différenciation par l'allégation
environnementale donc ça a donné
naissance évidemment à plusieurs
initiatives qui sont venu alors je ve
pas dire frontalement mais au moins
euh au moins de manière assez assez
forte en parallèle de ce qui est fait en
bio depuis depuis 40 ans et donc de ce
fait comme n'importe comme sur n'importe
quelle filière économique les
consommateurs ont besoin de plus
d'information pour pour faire le tri et
pour être éclairé et faire le bon choix
et que on mette de côté les les
allégations qui qui leur qui ne les
satisfont pas et au contraire peut-être
leur redonner confiance dans des choses
qui sont solides sur des C descharges
qui qui ont montré leur preuv depuis
depuis toujours Guillin
Cambier merci madame la Présidente
euh je viens d'un territoire lavenois
dans le Nord qui est qui porte la plus
grande surface agricole utile bio des
haute-fance donc c'est un thème qui nous
est particulièrement sensible donc
j'aurai une question pour pour chacun
parce que je vois beaucoup de mes
agriculteurs éleveurs ou ou producteurs
de manière générale un peu déboussolé
dans dans le contexte actuel la première
c'est pour Madame la Directrice on par
on a beaucoup parlé d'adois et Galim qui
est qui est en route depuis 2022 qui
fixe un certain nombre d'objectifs plus
ou moins ambitieux selon selon son
positionnement mais ce que l'on constate
c'est que les décideurs locaux soit sont
Pasu informés soit n'ont pas les moyens
non plus d'appliquer dans les euh dans
leur cantine en particulier ce type de
d'orientation et ma question elle est
est-ce qu'il y a un suivi de cette loi
Galim est-ce qu'il y a des contrôles qui
sont effectués et quant à Monsieur le le
président que je remercie également de
son exposé je vais prendre l'exemple de
la filière lait bio qui actuellement le
lait bio est est vendu à un prix
inférieur au lait au lait conventionnel
certains pointent d'ailleurs la la marge
prise par les la grande distribution
dans
dans ce domaine et ma question courte
c'est donc de savoir est-ce que vous
avez un plan justement d'orientation ou
de soutien de structuration de la
filière les bios de façon à ce qu'on
n'assiste pas soit à un déclassement
soit un déconventionnement puisque en
même temps certains certains produits ou
certaines orientations parfois on va
soutenir l'installation de l'agriculteur
en bio et puis on diminue ensuite les
aides de maintien et donc on est on est
un peu coincé voilà pour mes deux
questions madame la
Présidente
sur le suivi le contrôle des de la
réalisation des objectifs égalim un
outil a été mis en place par la DGAL la
direction générale l'alimentation qui
s'appelle donc ma cantine qui est un
outil déclaratif et aussi un voilà
déclaratif il n'y a pas de contrôle pour
l'instant il y a à peu près 10 % des
80000 cantines françaises qui déclarent
qui sont enregistré et qui déclarent ce
qu'elles font pas forcément jusqu'à la
question sur le bio dans l'outil
maantine mais on espère bien que ce sera
effectivement l'outil de suivi ça
n'aurait pas de sens que chacun fasse
son fichier Excel dans son coin pour
déclarer ses sa part de bio on utilise
nous beaucoup nos enquêtes on est obligé
pour l'instant de de s'occuper de de se
baser sur des enquêtes annuelles que
nous faisons pour estimer la part de bio
on espère que ma cantine et puis des
contrôles pourront permettre de booster
le recours du bio euh par les
cantines est-ce que vous ralentissez si
le le radar ne vous donne pas
d'amende vous avez un compteur ah oui
c'est
vrai
effectivement on a le le sujet en fait
c'est plutôt qu'on n' pas encore
pollinisé on a énormément de cantines
qui font 50 60 70 % de bio avec le même
budget et pourtant ben encore une fois
pas on manque de moyens pour faire
passer ce message plus largement que oui
ils savent faire un repas à 1,80 € en
coup matière avec 70 % de bio voilà
comment ils font et ça ne dépend pas que
de l'aliment c'est aussi le
fonctionnement c'est même les
restaurants qui arrivent ils ont remis à
plat leur politique énergétique ils ont
investi dans des fours programmables
pour diminuer leur leur consommation
d'énergie ils ont ils ont toute une
palette ils ont toute une boîte à outil
qui va bien au-delà de bioon bio ça
s'appelle la transition alimentaire et
ça dépasse le clivage bioon
bio merci pour pour votre question sur
la sur la filière laitière et je suis
attaché à votre à votre région tellement
chaque chaque effort pour aller un peu
plus loin dans le bio mérite d'être
souligné le contexte n'étant pas facile
sur le plan agricole pour faire la
transition des pratiques en tout cas je
je soulligne les efforts qui sont faits
dans cette région là sur la filière
laitière CIT c'est l'exemple parfait
dans lequel on verrait justement
l'efficacité aujourd'hui d'un dispositif
qui permettrait d'agir sur ces de TR qu
leviers de régulation justement de cet
écart entre offre et demande aujourd'hui
le déclassement il atteint des niveaux
jamais enfin pas supportable jamais
atteint pour la plupart des filières les
seuls qui peuvent le supporter donc ne
pas faire répercuter au producteurs sont
les plus gros acteurs conventionnels qui
se sont mis à faire du bio quand ça leur
semblait être opportun et qui
aujourd'hui considère que ça vaut encore
le coup de garder des adhérents sous
leur giron en en considérant qu'on peut
payer le le prix le prix du lait mais
aujourd'hui on verrait l'intérêt de de
ces outils de régulation pour justement
que ce soit pas les opérateurs
économiques qui supportent mais que on
est un support ponctuel par les les
pouvoirs publics de cette excellente
production et que tout le monde garde sa
sa résilience et son inertie pour
pouvoir repartir quand les moyens àouer
à la consommation et et à la et à la
demande seront seront au rendez-vous et
pour terminer sur ce sur ce sujetl parce
que vous abordiez la question de la
marge évidemment on n a pas spécialement
parlé aujourd'hui mais tout l'enjeu est
là ce discrédit qui nous qui nous qui
nous colle à la peau depuis si longtemps
de produits surpayés qui engresse tantôt
le transformateur tantôt le distributeur
et puis peut-être finalement le
producteur à la fin mais qui dit la
vérité sur ce sujet-là on a en France un
observatoire des prix et des marges qui
ne travaille que deux produits bio quand
est-ce qu'on aura un juge de paix qui
dira qui s'engresse sur l'autre dans les
filières bio aujourd'hui on n sait rien
donc le discrédit continue
malheureusement c'est valable pour les
produits laitiers comme pour comme pour
beaucoup d'autres bien
entendu Daniel
salmon merci madame la Présidente merci
pour vos exposés beaucoup de choses ont
déjà été
sur des causes structurelles de la crise
du bio je pense à la fin de l'aide au
maintien sur le HVE les écorégimes qui
ont été élarg et qui arrose aujourd'hui
tout le monde même sans aucune aucun
progrès en
terme de problématique environnementale
et puis beaucoup sur le pouvoir d'achat
moi j'aimerais que vous nous disiez
concernant le pouvoir d'achat quel est
le vrai prix le vrai prix entre le bio
et le conventionnel
est-ce que l'on prend bien en cause
toutes les externalités les externalités
positives et négatives est-ce que une
partie des charge du conventionnel ne
serait pas à la charge
justement du du contribuable voilà il y
a vraiment une question de prix parce
que on revient toujours sur le coût du
bio mais je pense qu'on ne prend pas en
compte vraiment l'ensemble de ces
problématiques deuxième question c'est
les outils vous en avez parlé mais les
outils qui sont utilisés en général pour
toutes les filières en crise qui ne sont
pas utilisés pour sauvegarder la filière
bio et comment ça se fait est-ce qu'il
n'y a pas un deux poids de mesure
j'aimerais bien que vous nous éclairiez
là-dessus et puis après tout simplement
quel est l'intérêt du bio est-ce que le
bio doit survivre est-ce qu'il a un
intérêt pour la biodiversité et pour la
lutte contre réchauffement climatique
Madame et
Monsieur alors pardon je me permettrait
de de commencer sur le vrai prix du
bio je crois que votre question elle
elle refite finalement la distance
compris les Françaises et les Français
avec l'origine de leur
alimentation qui produit
où comment et finalement à quel prix
chaque jour qui passe nous
éloigne de ces questions essentielles
sur l'appropriation de notre
alimentation on vit entre guillemets et
pour la très grande majorité d'entre
vous pas la totalité malheureusement
mais une période où on est en suffisance
voire en abondance et en période
d'abondance évidemment on peut se
permettre bah de s'éloigner des enjeux
fondamentaux et finalement de de
s'éloigner aussi de ce qui fait que
aujourd'hui toute une grande partie de
notre alimentation est subventionnée qui
en a conscience aujourd'hui quels
concitoyennes concitoyens ont conscience
aujourd'hui que dans l'achat d'une
baguette de pain ou ou d'un d'un kilo de
n'importe quel autre produit il y a une
d'argent public qui vient directement
qui vient aider au paiement personne ne
le sait donc on s'est éloigné et ce qui
fait qu'on s'est éloigné aussi de
finalement de toutes les externalités
qu' peut y avoir à l'agriculture et
comme le montrait la Cour des comptes
sur le prix de dépollution de l'eau les
enjeux de dépollution aujourd'hui
aggravé par la perte par la perte
d'autonomie en quantité avec des effets
de dilution qu'on ne peut plus obtenir
va devenir catastrophique ces enjeuxl
aujourd'hui ne sont pas considérés
évidemment par par nos nos concitoyennes
et nos concitoyens et il en a il y en a
évidemment bien d'autres parce que les
pertes de biodiversité et et les les
incidences sur le climat qui pourrai
être compensé he par un marché carbone
qui d'un seul coup viendrait solutionner
tous les enjeux aujourd'hui c'est pas le
cas du tout le marché biodiversité le
marché carbone n'est pas au rendez-vous
ni du revenu des producteurs ni
finalement de la solution pour les
transition donc le vrai prix de
l'alimentation premièrement le vrai prix
du bio aujourd'hui on a besoin de
communiquer d'informer les concitoyens
encore faut-il qu'ils aient un appétit
aussi pour s'informer de ce que c'est
que manger de ce qu' mettent dans le
dans leur assiette et puis sur les
outils de régulation on on l'a vu
malheureusement avec avec les les
épisodes passés quand on a eu des aides
des aides conjoncturelles pour certaines
filières les les outils de régulation
malheureusement sont souvent calibré
pour la production majeure la production
massive dans le pays et la pl plart du
temps on a des effets de seuil sur des
volumes ou des effets très restrictifs
sur sur des filières bien précises qui
font que malheureusement l'outil est
surdimensionné et mal adapté par rapport
à nos besoins aujourd'hui ce qui me fait
dire que finalement dans ce travail de
recherche de de meilleure structure dans
la régulation de marché on a aussi à
inventer beaucoup de choses tellement
les outils actuels malheureusement sont
calibré pour une agriculture qui est en
avance en matière de poids économique et
en matière de capacité de production
c'est une forme d'avance nous pour la
forme d'avance qu'on prétend sur la sur
l'eau la biodiversité et le climat la
santé de chacun on n' pas ces outils là
donc on va devoir sans doute sans doute
inventer à l'Agence Bio nous
interrogeons chaque année depuis 20 ans
plus de 4000 français représentatifs sur
leur rapport au bio ce qui nous permet
de vous dire que la la crise du bio elle
est un petit peu conjoncturel lié à
l'inflation
lié tourment en ce moment de la
consommation à la déconsom consommation
massive du bio de l'alimentaire qui
touche ai bio mais elle est surtout
structurelle elle est structurelle parce
que jusqu'ici le bio a conquis des gens
qui étaient autodidactes qui se
formaient sur le bio qui se
renseignaient en revanche il ne pourra
passer le cap que si il continueent il
gardent c'est des gens qui sont venus au
bio de façon un peu opportuniste parce
qu'ils ont trouvé dans les rayons sans
pour autant qu'ils sachent pourquoi le
bio est
bon je vous l'ai dit à pouvoir d'achat
égal l'éducation est clé c'est ce qui
fait que on consomme beaucoup ou pas du
tout de bio à pouvoir d'achat égal
actuellement les Français qui nous
disent moi je ne mange pas bio ils nous
disent que c'est un parce qu'ils ne
savent pas ce qu'il y a dans derrière le
label de ils s'en méfi TR ils pensent
que c'est du marketing ce qui est quand
même un peu fort de café puisque c'est
un diplôme d'état c'est un peu comme si
un médecin diplômé d'état vous refusez
de faire soigner s Prex que c'est du
marketing b non pour un énergéticien un
rebouteux ou quoi je je pour on pourrait
le concevoir mais quand on est diplômé
d'État a priori on peut avoir la
confiance en fait le bio c'est un peu
comme si c'était euh une monnaie
garantie par une banque centrale mais
qui suscite autant de méfiance queune
cryptonnaie donc il faudrait urgemment
remettre les choses au centre pour que
les consommateurs puissent opter quand
vous parlez de la concurrence je crois
monsieur des de des des autres labels
effectivement le bio nous à l'Agence Bio
on a un budget historiquement de
communication de 500000 € alors que les
budgets de communication des autres des
enseignes de des marques ce se chiffre
en centaines de millions d'euros c'estàd
que certaines marques
pour vendre des produits avec un
nutriscore peut-être Z ont des dizaines
de millions d'euros pour vous dire qu'il
y a du calcium dedans pour vos enfants
donc on ne se on ne se va pas arm égal
donc à partir du moment où le le
capitalisme s'arrête pas à la porte du
bio le bio on va pas pouvoir se passer
d'armes que pour expliquer au
consommateurs les bienfaits du bio il
faut que le bio ait les moyens de
communiquer à des heures de grande
écoute et surtout le
le l'enjeu aussi c'est que le bio fasse
fasse partie de toutes les tables on a
beaucoup parlé de consommation à
domicile mais la restauration collective
reste clé et la restauration commerciale
la restauration comme celle que vous
avez j'imagine au Sénat est aussi
décisive donc je je pense que si le
Sénat lui-même ne soutient pas sur son
menu l'agriculture plurielle de que nous
avons dans le bio c'est c'est c'est une
perte de chance alors si c'est collectif
c'est valable aussi dans les deux cas le
on a s'il est soumis aux objectifs de 20
% bio il faut que cette la carte le menu
du Sénat puisse refléter notre
agriculture plurielle don le bu Serge
merilou oui bonjour bonjour à tous moi
je suis élu dans un département
conseiller départemental dans un
département dans lequel le Conseil
départemental a initié au niveau de la
restauration scolaire collective le 100
% bio 100 % local 100 % fait maison ce
qui à redonné
d'ailleurs au cuisiners une autre
facette de leur métier ils ne sont plus
à ouvrir des boîtes ou à ouvrir des des
poches et ça redonnait du sens à leur
métier c'est un vrai choix politique qui
a été initié dans ce département et on
commence à avoir quelques années de
recul mais bon on va aller vite euh les
objectifs de la loi égalim pour 2022 sur
la concernant la part du bio dans la
restauration collective ne sont pas
atteints on on l'a dit et dans un
contexte économique dans laquelle la
consommation du bio à domicile n'est pas
accessible pour un grand nombre euh pour
un grand nombre de ménages des ménages
qui ont des revenus qui ne permettent
pas d'accéder à à ce à ces produitsl il
nous
paraît que la restauration collective la
restauration scolaire peut- être un
moyen pour les enfants et pour les
ménages d'accéder de découvrir ces
produits et donc ma question c'est selon
vous comment peut-on accélérer la part
du bio dans la restauration collective
quels sont les freins que vous
identifiez et puis un vœu que l'on
arrête d'opposer euh le bio et les
autres signes officiels de qualité il y
a la place pour tout le monde et et et
avec pourcentage de bio malheureusement
faible à hauteur de 6 7 % euh il faut
bien que l'on cohabite et et je suis
navré de voir qu'en permanence on est
dans un affrontement alors qu'on a
besoin euh de toutes les
agricultures
merci qui veut répondre alors merci pour
pour cet exemple que vous citez et c'est
un de plus un exemple de plus de
collectivité quelle que soit la taille
ou justement on a choisi d'emboîer le
pas à des précédents mais on a choisi
aussi d'aller plus loin et et coûte que
coûte j'imagine ça a dû être quoi qu'il
en coûte à ce moment-là d'aller vers ce
genre de décision même si le le résultat
est sûrement pas au goût de de tout le
monde en tout cas on montre que c'est
possible et qu' qu'avec un choix
politique on arrive peut-être pas au
niveau que vous vous avez cité mais on
arrive à faire bouger les choses ou en
tout cas un peu plus vite que ça que
simplement ce que ce qu'une loi peut
enfin juste juste incitatif peut faire
donc cet exemple là çaen est un de plus
et CEN est un de plus qui montre que on
a la possibilité aussi d'améliorer cette
découverte des produits bio par des
actions qui sont mené en en en à
destination des familles qui en sont les
plus éloignés donc on a des défis
famille à alimentation positive qui sont
à peu près répandus dans toutes dans
tous les départements où on travaille
avec les collectivité dans
l'accompagnement social à la découverte
des produits bio mais de la même manière
que ça peut se faire dans les cuisines
collectives euh des gens qui ouvrent des
boîtes ou réchauffent dans les cuisines
collectives malheureusement c'est c'est
le symbole aussi de gens qui chez eux
ouvrent des boîtes et réchauffent tout
simplement donc cette réappropriation
des produits bruts cette réappropriation
des produits locaux ça se fait aussi
malheureusement dans des proportions qui
sont encore pas au rendez-vous mais en
tout cas c'est ce qui est semble-t-il
aussi un un levier pour simplement
au-delà du budget que la volonté et la
sensibilité soit soit au rendez-vous
alors pour augmenter cette part du bio
on a toujours beaucoup d'inertie
malheureusement d'une réglementation des
achats publics qui traînent qui évoluent
mais malheureusement à un rythme qui
n'est qui n'est pas suffisant pour que
chaque acheteur dans son établissement
ou à chaque chaque acteuse dans son
établissement puisse recourir beaucoup
plus facilement à des des liens plus
étroits avec les productrices et les
producteurs locaux que ce soit sous
signe de qualité ou pas mais en tout cas
on a une inercie réglementaire ensuite
on a et vous le savez toutes les régions
qui sont interrogées sur ce qui se passe
dans les lycées redisent à l'envie que
elles n'ont pas la main sur les agents
de l'État qui sont chargés des achats
peut-être qu'il y a un levier à
actionner de ce côté-là et enfin pour
terminer je crois qu'on peut prendre
aussi des exemples sur plusieurs régions
et je veux pas faire de classement
discrimination ici mais en tout cas un
coup de pouce à l'achat égalim donc un
coup de pouce de 10 20 centimes sur le
prix d'un repas pour aller en direction
des objectifs égalim ce sont des
initiatives qui
malheureusement ne sont pas possible
pour tout le monde et malheureusement ce
font finalement qu'en action dérobé par
rapport à ce que peut-être on pourrait
attendre aussi de la part de l'État en
matière de de dynamisation de de l'achat
bio en restauration
collective
compliqué euh juste dans les freins vous
nous avez posé la question explicitement
des freins il y en a deux que je vois au
quotidien parce que nous rencontrons en
permanence des chefrs qui sont peut-être
pas à 100 % mais à 50 70 % et d'ailleurs
vous êtes tous les bienvenus sur notre
stand SMCL parce que c'est là où nous
les mettons en valeur actuellement il y
a deux grands freins le premier c'est
que le CAP cuisine vous pouvez regarder
il y a aucune occurrence du mot bio ou
même de transition agroécologique ou de
saisonalité ou de antiaspie or on sait
que si on veut mettre plus de BI au menu
il fautêt être hyper bon en antigaspie
il faut cuisiner plus on peut plus
acheter des pestos déjà fait c'est trop
cher il faut toujours cuisiner soi-même
donc le le le premier frein à lever ce
serait que le CAP Cuisine évoque le bio
tout au long de la formation du CAP
Cuisine et pas juste 4 heures à la fin
noyer au milieu des eutes psycho parce
qu'en fait le bio c'est un mode de
production et donc c'est une are
approche et donc si on veut plus
connecter nos chefs gastronomique et nos
chefs même pas gastronomiqu et nos
agriculteurs le CAP Cuisine est super
boutil et donc je crois qu'il il va y
avoir une réforme des référentiels c'est
là où ça va se jouer et le deuxième
frein qu'on voit parce que nous on
finance effectivement on a des
agriculteurs qui viennent n voir en
disant bah ça y est je me suis mis à
faire des yaourts et des fromages blancs
mais j'ai du mal à vendre à la cantine
du coin et souvent c'est un problème de
de conditionnement c'est-à-dire que la
cantine elle veut un pot de 5 kg et eux
ils font des pots de 250 g donc souvent
il y a besoin d'adéquation et c'est là
où le pat le programme alimentaire
territorial joue un rôle absolument
extraordinaire en en proportion souvent
marqueun Pat qui qui cartonne et qui
lève ses freins c'est en général 5 si
chargés de mission pour à peu près 150
200000 ventres à nourrir et là ce sont
des gens qui vont sur le terrain et qui
vont voir l'abattoir qui vont voir
l'éleveur qui vont voir la cantine qui
mett tout le monde autour de la table en
disant bon comment on fait pour vous
achetiez les bêtes sur place sur pied
que ça passe par l'abattoir et
qu'ensuite une fois que ça arrive dans
la cantine on puisse gérer toute une
carcasse plutôt que d'acheter des filets
déjà levés chez micro métro et ça il y a
il y a des exemples extraordina ire ou
par exemple à roubet le chef de canting
zavier Verquin vous dit moi j'ai
embauché un boucher bon carrément fait
oui oui ben c'est très bien parce que
comme ça à chaque fois qu'on a une
carcasse de bœuf qui arrive une fois par
mois bah chez vous aussi bah c'est la
solution sauf que derrière c'est quoi
c'est de l'humain donc effectivement si
on veut pas devoir payer le surcût au
quotidien du bio faut revoir son
fonctionnement et typiquement quand on a
des chargés de mission qui font le lien
entre la cantine le chef l'abattoir
logisticien et qui permettent de
connecter ces deux mondes on arrive à
faire le même menu pour moins cher avec
du bureau menu merci Yannick J on essaie
de d'accélérer un petit peu sans vous
brimer merci madame la Présidente deux
questions très courtes un euh il faut
arrêter de penser que l'économie
agricole dans notre pays est en et en
Europe est une économie proche d'être
une économie libérale de marché je veux
dire dans notre pays on met 12 13
milliards d'euros par an de soutien
direct à l'agriculture que ça soit la
PAC ou l'argent public français et puis
il y a on a parlé des externalités on
pourrait parler de la redevance sur
l'eau du traitement donc c'est une
économie organisé et c'est une bonne
chose que ce soit une économie organisée
à partir de là qu'est-ce qu'on fait de
cet argent et donc là j'ai deux
questions pour nos intervenant
un du côté
de du bio
euh comment vous expliquez que au fond
le le tirage classique pour une une
campagne de promotion en soutien aux
filières agricoes c'est 30 millions
généralement comment vous expliquz que
sur le bio on soit passé à 5 millions et
puis par rapport à la bio est-ce que
vous avez une évaluation parce que tous
les labels ils sont pas spontanés ces
labels ils ont été construits
politiquement et est-ce que du côté de
la FNAB vous avez une évaluation de la
diversion qui a pu
avoir du de la bio vers h par exemple en
terme de soutien et notamment autour de
toutes les mesures agréenvironnementales
et corrigé
merci alors très rapidement
euh sur l'information des citoyens don
dont on parle beaucoup ce matin et c'est
tant mieux les annonces qui ont été
faites aujourd'hui de 5 millions d'euros
supplémentaires pendant pendant 3 ans ce
sont des des des moyens qui viennent de
la planification écologique c'est dans
le cadre de la planification écologique
qu'on va avoir davantage de moyens en
aucun cas ce sont des des
du financement c'est c'est du
financement qui est comparable à
d'autres opérations de communication la
plupart du temps quand on commence à
chiffrer en dizaines de millions d'euros
les opérations de communication ça veut
dire que les interprofessions se sont
chargés du sujet se sont mobilisés pour
avoir du résultat à à hauteur de de ce
qu'elles attendent et et la plupart du
temps effectivement pour être efficace
c'est en dizaines de millions d'euros
que ça se chiffre aujourd'hui toutes les
agricultrices et les culteur finance ces
interprofessions par l'intermédiaire de
de contribution qui sont collectés à la
source et c'est ces contributions vont
abonder un budget qui est tantôt orienté
vers de la recherche vers de la
communication ou ou d'autres mais en
tout cas ces orientations budgétaires là
elles se font au sein d'une
interprofession qui évidemment
aujourd'hui quand même majoritairement
et depuis longtemps tourné vers une
agriculture bah qui n'a pas grand-chose
de bio donc même si les choses changent
positivement et et et c'est c'est c'est
divers selon les filières il y a encore
beaucoup beaucoup de travail à faire
là-dessus monsieur le ministre semblait
s'inquiéter justement de cette
rétiscence qui pouvait y avoir dans les
interprofession à aller un peu plus loin
encore dans le financement des campagnes
de communication c'est une bonne chose
encore faut-il maintenant que ça puisse
se concrétiser et qu'enfin on arrive à
franchir ce seuil cette masse critique
de finances pour la communication certes
on a eu 5 % de mieux par une campagne
biorflex montée finalement avec grand
avec grand talent mais mais finalement
juste avec 1 million et demi 2 millions
quoi qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait gagner si
on si on multipliait par 2 3 4 5 10 on
imagine bien qu'aujourd'hui je serai pas
là ce matin devant vous pour parler des
difficultés de la filière bio on
pourrait peut-être parler du programme
ambition bio pour passer de 18 à 21 %
mais en tout cas je serai pas là pour
parler de difficulté donc aujourd'hui on
a besoin aussi de recentrer les moyens
qui sont mis au pot par tout tous les
productrices et les producteurs sous
sous forme de ces contributions il y a
un statut des interpros est-ce qu'il
faut une interprofession bio aujourd'hui
la question se pose peut-être qu'il faut
la construire mais à ce moment-là don
donnonsnous les moyens dans le cadre
juridique qu' permet d'avoir une une
interpr bio digne de ce nom avec les
budgets qui iront au bout moi je suis
prêt à en discuter évidemment donc ce
sujet-là ce sujet-l il est il est
crucial pour pour notre pour notre
développement je compléterai l'Adème qui
nous éduque à la transition énergétique
qui nous apprend donc à éteindre les
lumières à trier nos déchets il y a
encore quelques années c'était assez
exotique comme idée de consacrer 1 m
Carr à qure poubelles nous a éduqué sur
le long terme les budgets de
communication de laadè à destination du
grand public tournent aux alentours de
30 millions d'euros donc effectivement
ça nous donne une bonne indication de
combien on a besoin pour pouvoir éduquer
à la transition parce que c'est c'est
des changements d'usage c'est pas juste
dire manger bio ça Rambo ça ça suffira
pas ça ça pourra ponctuellement relancer
la la demande et peut-être faire en
sorte qu'on garde un notre patrimoine de
60000 fermes bio sans que certaines nous
soi perdu en route en revanche sur le
long terme c'est un enjeu d'éducation
c'est la consommation bio c'est un
écogeste dont il faut montrer donner le
mode d'emploi parce que oui chacun peut
manger bio quel que soit son pouvoir
d'achat c'est juste une question
peut-être de de jus de cerveau d'huile
de coude et d'énergie à louer à à son
alimentation mais nous sommes tous
d'accord sur le fait qu'il faut plus
réinvestir sur notre alimentation am ger
merci madame la Présidente je vais
evenenir rapidement sur l'objectif des
20 % de bio dans les restaurants
collectifs non atteints oui non atteint
aujourd'hui euh ce qui est mis en avant
en fait he par les par les restaurants
c'est c'est le prix des matières
premières aujourd'hui mais d'autres
freins beaucoup plus complexe encore ce
sont les filières locales pas assez
structurées ça a été dit pour répondre
en tout cas aux contraintes et je vais
prendre l'exemple d'un hôpital par
exemple qui peut avoir des exigences
importantes moi ce que je pointe du
doigt en fait ce sont les inégalités
territorial qui s'impose en fait
aujourd'hui aux qutines et aux citoyens
ma question est est très claire he
quelle piste concrète proposé pour PAL à
ça est-ce que dans l'objectif fixé des
18 % de surface bio en 2027 cette
inégalité territoriale est intégré et
puis autre sujet très bref c'est
l'accompagnement des collectivités
territoriales pour l'atteintre de cet
objectif est-ce qu'aujourd'hui il existe
et est-ce qu'il est suffisant je vous
remercie alors évidemment que que cette
cette diversité territoriale elle
s'ajoute et elle se superpose à la
diversité des productions et des et des
profil des des des fermes aujourd'hui à
ma
connaissance la la seule la seule
structuration des politiques
territoriales en matière d'alimentation
elle est passée par les Pat par des
moyens qui ont été mis en en avant on en
a déjà parlé tout à l'heure mais avec
avec du temps de construction de
coconstruction sur le terrain et de de
de mobilisation justement pour pour voir
les adéquations qui peut y avoir on a
travaillé depuis depuis maintenant
plusieurs années justement avec avec des
des gens plus spécialisés que nous à la
FNAB sur cette question d'adéquation
nous côté producteur vous Côté Acheteur
et puis et puis c'est mise en relation
ça abouti par exemple dans beaucoup
d'endroits à des plateformes logistiques
hein de mise en relation parce que nous
c'est pas notre métier d'aller d'aller
nous préparer à à l'achat de de la de la
de la restauration collective et c'est
pas leur métier de traîner la campagne
pour trouver les meilleurs produit donc
on a créé des maillons supplémentaires
pour une fois un maillon supplémentaire
ça avait tout son sens il y a des fois
on voudrait en supprimer il y en a trop
mais là ça avait tout son sens de mettre
un maillon supplémentaire donc des
plateformes du réseau manger bio elles
sont là à peu près dans toutes les
régions elles font elles font ce ce ce
ce travail de lien mais c'est
l'initiative d'une association ça n'a
rien de structurant rien d'obligatoire
évidemment et c'est porté à bout de bras
par des productrices et des producteurs
qui font ce travail là donc on a besoin
je vais le redire malheureusement que CP
qu'on ait une version de qui arrive très
rapidement pour que enfin on ait la
dimension égalim qui soit prise à la
hauteur des enjeux et que on se contente
pas maintenant d'installer allez quel
quelques partenariats par-ci par là avec
des producteurs locaux mais que ça en
reste là s'il vous plaît non qu'on s'en
arrête pas là parce que ça sera vra
vraiment un échec de relocalisation et
de transition alimentaire don pour moi
c'est c'est c'est l'outil
malheureusement qui a évidemment plus
que le mérite d'exister actuellement
mais sur lequel doit pouvoir compter
demain effectivement il y a une rupture
de l'égalité des citoyens vis-à-vis du
bio il y a des zones blanches il y a des
zones très bio ce qu'on constate c'est
que effectivement les Pat sont un
formidable outil pour essayer d'égaliser
ça et nous à l'Agence Bio on a des
sortes d'homologues régional qui sont
les interbios il n'en existe que dans
SEP régions sur 13 et qui font
effectivement ce travail de connecter
les régions les les demandes des
collectivités avec à la fois l'amont et
la v
donc effectivement il y aurait peut-être
une une piste à creuser puisque c'est
c'est soumis à l'aléa de la décision du
du président de Région Christian Redon
sarazi oui merci madame la Présidente en
ce qui concerne le financement du bio on
a un sentiment d'improvisation qui est
assez contradictoire avec les les
objectifs très ambitieux affichés par le
gouvernement 100 millions annoncés au
salon puis 60 millions pour l'aide
d'urgence puis encore div milons pour la
communication dans le même temps les
aides à la conversion du premier pilier
de la PAC sont sous-consommé en Ré de la
crise actuelle euh les écorégimes
passent donc à 92 € au lieu de 110 vous
plaidez donc pour un transfert du second
pilier vers le premier pilier mais comme
vient de le rappeler le ministère de
l'Agriculture il est impossible de
modifier le plan stratégique avant 2026
dans ces conditions quelle
architecture un peu plus durable de
financement public pourriez-vous
imaginer alors effectivement au regard
de ce scénario qui se confirme irmera
malheureusement que quand on aura des
chiffres définitifs sur la consommation
des enveloppes alloué à à la conversion
en l'agriculture
biologique 150 millions probablement
peut-être plus qui qui était destiné et
qui ont été longtemps mis de côté par
par nos interlocuteurs au ministère en
disant que bah il fallait attendre
confirmation des chiffres et puis de
toute façon il fallait attendre
peut-être l'arrivée de la fin de la PAC
pour voir ce qui resterait vraiment à
consommer aujourd'hui heureusement
j'espère qu'on va s'attaquer rapidement
au sujet de façon à ce que on soit pas
dans cette absurdité totale où on est en
manque de moyens conséquent pour des
filières qui sont en construction en
émergence d'un côté et de l'autre côté
une politique hyper volontariste qui a
mis beaucoup beaucoup sur la conversion
qui aurait peut-être mérité un peu de
modération parce que une conversion à
tout va sans finalement structurer c'est
peut-être c'était peut-être pas
raisonnable en tout cas c'est là
maintenant comment faire donc vous
l'avez dit des impossibilités techniques
qui nous sont avancées par le ministère
et assez souvent malheureusement la
rigidité de la pack qui fait que quand
bien même on a des des des des fenêtres
de faisabilité qui s'ouvrent de toute
façon c'est toujours à 1 an 2 ans voire
3 ans de mise en œuvre donc aujourd'hui
pour moi quand je vais retourner voir
mes collègues c'est évidemment pas des
réponses qui vont qui vont le les
satisfaire donc comment faire
aujourd'hui on a évidemment la question
du crédit d'impôt mais qui vient d'être
réévalué et qui finalement n'est pas
qu'une pas n'est pas une solution
structurelle on a la solution des
mesures agro-environnementales et
climatiques qui
aujourd'hui sont largement décriés aussi
par l'insuffisance des moyens qui sont
qui sont mis en face donc la solution
malheureusement au-delà
d'avoir dans un par exemple dans dans
dans le projet de loi de
finan une possibilité d'intervenir
ponctuellement justement sur une aide
produc producteur organisation de
producteurs qui puissent palier ce
manque le temps de de faire évoluer la
politique agricole commune et un travail
sur le sur la le le rééquilibrage entre
les différentes aides moi je demande
depuis depuis maintenant plusieurs mois
au ministère la la mise en place d'une
d'une instance de concertation et de
décision justement sur les moyens àouer
l'agriculture biologique puisque
aujourd'hui l'Europe l'État les régions
les agences de l'eau et d'autres
échelles de collectivité encore ont leur
mot à dire dans les objectifs de
développement sur leur territoire
personne ne se rencontre au niveau
national c'est toujours en bilatéral
jamais on a au niveau national ce qui se
passe dans les régions sous forme de
commission régionale
agro-environnementale et climatique dans
toutes les région il s'en tient au moins
deux par an avec un ordre du jour avec
des préparations avec des votes des
délibérations et des actions aujourd'hui
les agences de l'eau par exemple sont
demandeuses de ce genre d'instance là ça
n'a pas lieu au niveau national on en a
besoin aujourd'hui on en on devrait en
avoir depuis bien longtemps pour
anticiper la l'p dans laquelle on est
aujourd'hui on l'a pas mais c'est dans
ce genre d'instance là j'espère qu'elle
sera créée prochainement qu'on pourra
justement anticiper et peut-être
préparer des révisions du du plan
stratégique national qui auront un vrai
effet positif sur l'agriculture
biologique Rémi Cardon on accélère un
petit peu parce qu'on va devoir clôturer
notre audition pour pour faire court
puisque une partie de ma question été
euh posé euh nous le savons quoi qu'il
arrive on doit avoir une offre
biologique agriculture bio qui qui gagne
des terres et dans du terrain dans nos
assiettes mais aujourd'hui on a quand
même du mal au-delà des fonds d'urgence
et du fond avenir bio 2023 porté à 15
millions euh à y voir clair sur est-ce
qu'on va arriver nettement à l'objectif
de 18 % d'aller plus loin de s'approcher
plutôt des des 25 % et donc moi ma
question elle est très simple au-delà
des solutions que vous voulez de vous
venez de définir et et les différents
leviers est-ce que vous avez un
chiffrage réel à quelques mois d'un
d'une loi de programmation sur
l'agriculture justement voilà est-ce que
vous avez un chiffrage réel concret à à
nous
présenter aujourd'hui tout va dépendre
de du contenu qu'on aura dans le dans ce
programme ambition bio le programme
ambition bio va définir des des des
orientations
qui vont avoir des conséquences
malheureusement ce programme ambition
bio n'est pas adossé à un quelconque
mode de financement à un quelconque
schéma d'organisation de finances qui
qui fera foi par rapport à au au socle
de financement des aides qui qui a lieu
donc malheureusement on on pourra avoir
un dispositif qui sera précis ambitieux
axé tant sur l'installation que sur la
promotion que sur la production la
recherche aux alternatives ou autres en
face de ça moi tant qu'on aura pas un
ministère qui aura pris euh
euh la mesure de l'enjeu et qui sera
investi suffisamment aujourd'hui au
ministère de l'Agriculture hein les les
les les personnes qui sont au quotidien
sur l'agriculture biologique j'ai assez
d'une mains pour les compter donc tant
qu'on aura pas dépassé ce ce seuil là et
tant qu'on aura pas eu non plus de
changement d'échelle dans la
préoccupation du ministère sur
l'agriculture biologique malheureusement
on en restera euh
des malheureusement des initiatives qui
sont sûrement un peu décousu tant sur le
plan politique que sur le plan
économique avec la structuration des
filières Daniel gremiller
oui merci madame la Présidente en tant
que président du groupe de suivi égalim
avec ma collègue Anne Catherine noisier
je m'interroge vraiment sur le réalisme
de l'atteinte des 20 % de production bio
dans la restauration collective
notamment je vais être très bref puisque
le rapport remis par
le gouvernement au mois d'avril le
rapport du CGER et la situation des
cantine de l'administration montre que
le travail que nous avons fait au Sénat
dans le groupe de suivi est complètement
pertinent on est en plein dedans cont
tenu de la question qui a été posée par
Serge et celle d'Amel qui parce que en
fait c de savoir comment pouvons-nous et
je le dit notamment alors verdau qu'on
avait eu le plaisir d'auditionner cet
été c'est Édouard l'angle d'attaque pour
donner envie et voir comment dans la
restauration collective on pouvait
améliorer l'utilisation mais je vais je
coupe là ma question parce qu'il y a
plus de questions contenu vous y avez
déjà pratiquement
répondu est-ce que je peux juste élargir
et regarder ce que font nos voisins
européens il y avait le
congrèsz intéressant ah je m'en rappelle
plus mais je dois être probablement
d'accord avec moi-même mais vous me
redirez en fait il y avait il y avait le
Congrès européen de la bio qui s'est
tenu en Espagne en Andalousie d'ailleurs
le mois dernier et les Suédois nous
disait que leur objectif d'achat public
tout alimentaire confondu c'est 60 % de
bio et ils en sont à 35 % les Italiens
ont un objectif de 50 % de d'achat
public alimentaire en bio ils en sont à
20 % donc d'une manière générale on voit
que les exemples européens peuvent être
aspirants on a parlé beaucoup des Danois
qui mange 12 % de bio à la à la à la
maison mais à la cantine on a des
voisins qui ont des politiques beaucoup
plus ambitieuses et qui ont levé ces
freins là et notamment parce qu'ils ont
pu connecter tout cette affaire d'humain
à partir du moment où vous avez des
chargés de mission qui vont sur le
terrain et qui connectent les
différentes chaînes de de alimentaire on
se retrouve avec une une une cohérence
qui permet de réussir les objectifs que
la nation s'est s'est
fixé alors il nous reste Fabien Guay
Fabien non tu as plus de
question c'est qu' dire bonjour euh non
deux questions rapides la première je me
suis beaucoup intéressé au fead à à
l'aide alimentaire au plus démunis qui
est en train d'exploser ah pardon c'est
bien la première fois qu'on me dit
ça je me suis beaucoup intéressé au au
au à l'aide au plus démunis au fead
notamment c'est c'estes fonds européens
et il y a une question je pense que tous
les publics doivent avoir accès au
et au meilleur ça doit pas être réservé
à une élite et je consididère qu'on ne
fait pas assez sur l'aide au plus démuni
d'une part et qu'on ne fait rien pour
leur donner accès au bio donc je pense
que vous devez enfin quelle réflexion
vous menez sur ça et et c'est évidemment
très compliqué la deuxième c'est vous en
avez parlé mais juste un mot sur les
labels il y en a beaucoup beaucoup trop
on ne voit pas et vous l'avez dit Madame
la Directrice la première chose c'est
que le consommateur ou la consommatrice
ne s'y retrouve pas ne comprend pas tout
euh
entre enfin bon tous les tous les labels
donc quelle réflexion vous menez sur sur
cette question et puis la
dernière moi je suis un farouche
opposant avec mon groupe politique au
traité de libre échange et et je pense
que nous devrions avoir un une réflexion
tout ce qui est bio n'est pas bon pour
l'environnement moi je je je le dis
quand je je vais au supermarché que je
vois des Kiwii des avocats peu importe
bio venant de l'autre bout de la planète
j'ai une réflexion je pense que le bio
c'est d'abord du local et de la saison
et donc on peut pas placer à mon sens le
le bio euh produit ici et de façon
locale et celui qui fait quatre fois le
tour de la planète là on a là on a un
véritable problème donc quelle est votre
réflexion sur ces questions voilà
j'étais court
là le cahier des charges bio c'est 300
pages de mode d'emploi agronomique ça
dit comment c'est produit ça dit pas où
c'est produit c'est pas un code postal
donc je comprends tout à fait votre
point maintenant je rappelons que les
importations en bio
sont de 28 % et si on retire les
produits exotiqu qui de toute façon ne
pousseront pas bio ou pas bio sur nos
contr contré on on est même en dessous
de de ce taux-l comme je vous l'avais
indiqué sur le bio pour les toutes les
populations nous sommes entièrement
d'accord nous avons d'ailleurs fait le
le fêé la journée euréne de la bio cette
année au à l'imeum de l'Armée du Salut
puisque le groupe de restauration
sociale et et d'inclusion réfugy food
lui recours à une vingtaine de pourcent
de de de produits bio ça nous tenait à
cœur de montrer qu'effectivement même
dans les populations en situation de
précarité ont droit au bio et au bio de
qualité locale ils sont d'ailleurs en
partenariat avec la coopérative bio
d'île-de-fance et quant au bio qui
voyage rappelons comme laadem nous le
nous précise que l'empreinte
environnment
d'un aliment c'est 80 % son mode de
production c'est 20 % son transport donc
l'impact il est pas dans le réservoir du
camion qui l'emmène il est pas dans le
même dans le le réservoir de F du
tracteur qui labour il est dans le mode
de
production pard alors Bernard bu Laurent
s'il te
plaît merci présidente rapidement un
témoignage dans la Drome comme pour mon
collègue de la Dordogne nous avons mis
en place au niveau du département
on sert
1750000 repas par an dans les cantines
du département on était l'année passée
scolaire à 47 % de produit bio servi
avec un tarif moyen d'enrêt de 2,25 € je
vous donne des chiffres puisqu'on avait
la question hier et on a aujourd'hui
facturé aux familles 3,45 € voilà donc
le reste c'est une décision politique
comme dans la le collègue chez le
collègue et donc aujourd'hui pour savoir
les impayés on a moins de 1 % payé
puisqu'on aide avec des bourses
départementales et avec les fonds
sociaux de l'État voilà donc ma question
qui décoiffe peut-être le bio est-il
compatible avec les OGM autrement dit
notre société pourrait-elle bénéficier
d'une agriculture basée sur ces deux
procédés pour n'en tirer que des
avantages alors
que effectivement et pour faire très
rapide juste peut-être sur cette
dernière question qui qui se détache
vraiment du du du reste euh évidemment
que la question se pose aujourd'hui où
l'évolution du cadre du cadre
réglementaire et est est en complète
peut-être révolution dans la mesure où
ce qui est ce qui a été raccompagné
gentiment à la porte risque de rentrer
violemment par la fenêtre peu importe
sur ce que ça peut apporter
ou ou
finalement engendré comme nuisance ce
qu'on demande nous producteur bio c'est
la possibilité d'une
traçabilité insp enfin don dont la
probité et est absolu aujourd'hui ce qui
ce qui arrive va jeter un N risque de
jeter un nouveau discrédit sur
l'agriculture biologique on risque de se
retrouver dans peut-être dans une
prochaine émission où on va devoir
prouver que on a été indemne de toute
contamination donc que les produits
génétiquement modifiés cultivés par nos
voisins ne sont pas venus modifier
génétiquement nos production donc cet
enjeul là il est crucial pour nous peu
importe sur le débat de fond en tout cas
c'est sur la forme on a absolument
besoin d'une réglementation qui
garantisse une traçabilité et qui
garantissent la possibilité de respecter
notre cahier des charges je pourrais
prendre le cas de la de la contamination
au proculfocarb un produit aujourd'hui
qui est extrêmement volatile qui qui
court qui fait courir un danger à toutes
les productions qu'ell soi bio ou pas
bio d'ailleurs les contaminations
aujourd'hui sont le vrai sujet de crédit
de l'agriculture biologique et de
l'alimentation demain donc soyons
vigilant juste justement pour que aussi
sur la question génétique on ne on ne ne
laisse pas la porte ouverte aussi à des
discrédits sur sur l'alimentation du
alors dernière question Antoinette Gul
je m'excuse auprès de Philippe
grosvallet et de Jean-Marc Boyer parce
que vous étiez inscrit hors limite et
que l'on doit maintenant examiner le
rapport de notre notre collègue
annecatrine Loisier Antoinette Gul
dernière question oui merci madame la
Présidente alors déjà je voulais
remercier nos deux nos deux invités
alors d'une part pour ce qui vient
d'être dit mais également pour tout le
travail qui est fait quotidiennement au
cours des années parce que c'est très
précieux de pouvoir avoir une
agriculture biologique en France qui est
à la fois ce niveau et la diversité que
présente l'agriculture biologique
française moi j'ai en fait trois points
que j'aimerais aborder le premier qui
est un point un peu conjoncturel on sait
qu'on est en période d'inflation on est
en période d'inflation alimentaire forte
moi j'aimerais savoir concern
les produits bio quel est le rôle de la
grande distribution j'ai lu votre note
de conjoncture celle qui est publiée par
l'Agence Bio très régulièrement et je
constate qu'il y a toujours le même
process nous avons là une baisse de
volume importante que ce soit sur le
lait de vache bio que ce soit sur la
viande bovine ovine porsine que ce soit
sur les sur les œufs on a donc une
baisse de volume une augmentation de la
valeur pour les producteurs et une
augmentation du prix de vente qui est
nettement nettement supérieure à
l'addition des deux précédents
c'est-à-dire qu'en réalité il y a des
marges beaucoup plus importantes qui
sont faites par la grande distribution
en ce moment alors qu'on est en pleine
inflation sur les produits bio et donc
je dis que cette attaque là est une
attaque réelle que je constate en lisant
les chiffres he peut-être que mon
analyse mérite des précisions mais en
tout cas je me base sur vos chiffres je
trouve que ça pose la question de la
régulation des marges en particulier
pour les produits bio dans la grande
distribution c'est mon premier point mon
deuxè point oui r en fait j'ai deux
autres petites questions le deuxième
c'est fond avenir bio 18 millions
d'euros là on constate quand même aussi
les troit tesses des financements en
réalité qui sont donnés quand vous dites
qu'avec 18 millions de de d'euros vous
avez à gérer en fait toute l'innovation
de et la construction de nouvelles
filières bio et bien je trouve qu'on n
pas à la hauteur en fait de l'enjeu de
l'enjeu environnemental ça fait 4 mois
qu'on a les températures les plus
chaudes jamais enregistrées et on nous
dit qu'on met 18 millions dans le fond
avenir bio bah écoutez je trouve que là
on est très très en de ça de de ce que
mérite et dernier point sur les plus
défavorisé et j'arrêterai là est-ce que
la sécurité sociale alimentaire n'est
pas aussi une solution vous savez que
nous le portons fortement nous les
écologistes nous portons fortement cette
cette innovation est-ce que c'est pas
une solution aussi demand mon une
réponse très synthétique s'il vous plaît
alors je je fais de mon
mieux sur sur
l'inflation
qui qui qui qui se reflète évidemment
sur sur tous les paniers bio
malheureusement je crois que il est pas
il est pas temps de de d'incriminer un
mode de distribution ou un autre on sait
qu'on a des d'un côté des démarches de
commerce équitable qui viennent
labellliser des partenariats des
contrats au long cours qui sécurisent
les maillons de la filière de l'autre
côté et bien une parfaite liberté de
faire de de faire tout ce qui semble bon
à chaque chaque maillon aujourd'hui en
tout cas il faut que tout ça ça se fasse
dans le dans dans le minimum de
transparence quand il y a lieu d'avoir
de la transparence donc je reviens sur
la question de l'Observatoire des prix
et des marges pour moi la solution elle
est quand même en grande partie en
grande partie là et s'il y a des acteurs
qui dépassent la ligne rouge et bien à
ce moment-là que ce que ce soit à la
connaissance peu importe d'une
réglementation mais au moins des
consommateurs donc juste pour terminer
sur le sur le sur la sécurité sociale
alimentaire puisque le fond avenir bio
effectivement on en a parlé sécurité
sociale alimentaire moi pour moi ça me
rapproche tout simplement de des sujets
suj qu'on a abordé jusqu'à présent sur
finalement le vrai coût de
l'alimentation sur la part subventionnée
de l'alimentation hein ce qui vient de
la pack est-ce que il faudrait pas
rajouter à un moment donné de la même
manière qu'aujourd'hui sur le transport
j'aime bien faire cette analogie entre
l'alimentation et les transports on a
des des régions en France où on parle de
rendre le transport en commun gratuit et
et à d'autres moments où on va être au
contraire sur privilégier l'utilisation
de voitures personnelles avec une seule
personne dedans donc il faut faut se
poser questions là et est-ce qu'on
pourrait imaginer justement qu'on ait
une part de de revenus garanti
systématiquement pour l'alimentation je
pense que le débat se pose aujourd'hui
puisquon est en en pleine période de
transition alimentaire voilà merci au
nom de l'ensemble de nos collègues de la
commission monsieur le Président Madame
la Directrice on savait que ce débat all
être passionné ils le sont ils sont tout
autant passionnants et je pense qu'on
aura d'autres occasions de nouveau pour
évoquer la question de l'agriculture
d'une façon générale et de l'agriculture
biologique bien sûr merci beaucoup